the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
epic battles with dramatic results ruled
the day at the feed a candidates in
madrid spain ian napomniachi and fabiano
carawana drew their all-important
matchup with the former nursing a
one-point lead over the american however
the bottom of the bracket rebounded in
decisive fashion with ding loren timor
rajabov and alareza farrugia all winning
their games it's still anyone's
tournament to win who will prove worthy
round 10 of legendary chess coming up
next
[Music]
hello and welcome to our live coverage
of the 2022 candidates tournament from
madrid spain we are live in our studio
in saint louis ready to bring you all
the action of this round well good good
morning everyone dorsey hello yes sir
how's it going wonderful how did you
like your free day
very eventful very wonderful i feel like
such an adult now i signed my lease so i
have a key i'm paying utilities
sweet welcome welcome we got more bills
for you hello everyone uh so far
it's been a one horse race one nepo is
galloping away
but the knock
against nepo is that sometimes he
falters down the stretch
will he silence his critics as our
colleague christian would say only time
will tell let's take a look at our
standings dorsey yes please
at the very top we have jan at six and a
half points wow then it's fabi following
by five and a half followed by
uh hikaru by
nine and uh four and a half and ding
levin is yeah tied with him
unfortunately in the cellar is duda
all by himself
not a good place to be and our format
uh dorsa it's a very very special format
since it's the eight player double round
robin and there's a hundred twenty
minutes for the first 40 move
followed by 60 minutes for the next 20
move and the final 15 minutes plus 30
second increment for the rest of the
game very nice no draw offers before
black's 40th move half a million euros
in prize money uh we have our schedule
and our pace has been three games free
day three games free day and we're just
coming off a free day so
here's where we stand on wednesday june
29th round 10 followed by around 11
12. wow it's july already exactly rest
day
and then the closing
rounds runs 13 and 14. we will have an
extra day of playoffs if necessary more
on that later but in the meanwhile we
have our very good friend alejandro good
morning sir
in studio to tell us about the players
roads ahead good morning yasser good
morning dorsa pleasure to be with both
of you here early morning in st louis
but always happy to be casting these
games and you guys mentioned it it's all
about nepo and players are starting to
look at that schedule ahead say there's
not that many games left for the players
that are chasing nepo well that means
getting some points but for this man it
means getting solid results if he can
cruise control all the way to the end
even if he just makes draws he's still a
clear favorite to take the tournament
clearly he will be starting his venture
today round 10 with the white pieces
against temura jabot they drew on their
first bout and tomorrow he'll be playing
with
black against ali reza ferruccio
remember in that game alireza brought a
great amount of preparation with the
black pieces that allareza but
it was nepal that found himself
in the style of chess that he likes and
he took alireza showed him exactly how
to play those open positions and just
demolished him off the board meanwhile
in round 12 to finish this trio of games
he'll be playing against hikaru nakamura
who had a bit of a surge but was stopped
by tamor just recently meanwhile the
only person that can really
realistically catch nepo is this man
fabiano carrana he's still a full point
behind nepo it's a lot and he has a
tough road ahead he's playing black
against duda today who has not had a big
tournament but tomorrow he will be white
against dingley ren dingley red just won
his first game of the candidates surely
he wants to improve his result before
finishing this event and then he'll be
black again a lot of blacks coming into
favi's road ahead he'll be black against
richard rapport who he drew with in the
first half of the event and why are we
talking about these two guys because the
numbers say so nepalniacci was a 77
favorite to take the tournament even
before the last round it all hinged on
his results against fabiano corrada they
had their head to head
there was no decisive result in that one
and that means that jan de pomnyacci's
chances to win this event catapulted
even further 85.8 percent is what the
numbers are giving him fabiano carrana
dropping because of that and take a look
at the rest of the field dingleran with
1.1 percent is the only person above one
percent chance of winning this
tournament do you guys believe in these
numbers do you give dingler and a one
percent chance to win with five rounds
to go yasser it feels like there's a lot
of chess left in madrid there is a lot
of chess left in madrid and the idea
that there's only a one percent is
remarkable to me what a model that we're
using but
please dorsa set the stage for us uh set
the table for us for today's pairings
well we have rapports paired against
dink dude versus caruana that's a huge
match oh yes then it's followed by
nipple plane versus rajabov
we've been discussing it was okay for
them but this is a big game naka versus
first row every single of these games
are getting really interesting because
we have such an eventful day before the
rest day indeed and so many players like
farrugia lightning won their very first
game now if i'm in nakamura's shoes i'm
really happy to play somebody who has a
lower score than my i do i'm thinking
okay they're an easy target none of
these guys are very easy target but
there's big fights
for the money and break down the top
three prizes for us dorset please well
it's a total of half a million
euro prize pool the first prize is 48
000 euros second price is the 36 000
followed by third price which is 24 000
here
euros exactly and it's but it's more
like uh winner takes off yes because
it's all about
becoming the challenger winning this
event
challenging this man grandmaster magnus
carlson
for the 2023 world championship
championship match at a site still to be
determined we think that that's a match
with a 2 million euro prize fund ahead
so whoever becomes the challenger very
very very happy to be sure about that
now as we get set for
this round 10 i want to try to
get alejandro
as a take on this i i'm hikaru nakamura
okay i need to win this game because
my chances might be less than one
percent
and i'm playing against a guy okay
forget the fact that he's one of the
highest rated players in the world
but he does play the king's indian with
black right
where is farouza's weakness where should
nakamura in your opinion strike
well that's what we're gonna have to
find out today because out of all the
games that we have today there's two
where i think one side is just gonna try
to kill the other right and they all
this is going to be one of them i think
hikaru is very angry that he just lost
the game he felt that he had chances in
the tournament and that he himself
destroyed them to get back he needs to
try to beat firouja even to have a wild
shot right so this is going to be an
impressive one and i agree furuja has
had some shaky preparation i'm going to
tell you why it's not the fact that he
gets in the moves themselves
but i feel that sometimes he gets the
preparation in and he gets these
positions that he doesn't fully
understand
he played like that against nepo where i
felt that he had a very very sharp very
cool idea played in
but the moment the game left the waters
he didn't know how to handle it
first is still a young player he still
has a lot to learn
he's still a bit of a moving target and
a bit of a mystery he hasn't played as
much classical chess as some of the
other competitors and he hasn't had a
stable repertoire as long as some of the
other competitors you can prepare
against favis petrov that goes back
years and years and years but you can't
go back years and years and years with
laressa he wasn't a gm yet
he's such a young player now where do i
think he's going to go i think that
these players prepare very specifically
for tournaments and hicaro's brought e4
in
i would be very surprised if he doesn't
start with the movie four and hope that
alireza plays a sicilian
right
and there you go
and that's why you get the big box
alejandro you predicted it are we gonna
see an open nighter
that would be my expectation yeah i
think i don't think alireza is playing
any other sicilian at this level of
chess we've seen richie throw in
taimanov uh we've seen a lot of people
throw in uh four knight sicilian and
special cops but it's not alireza's
repertoire he's normally a neidorf
player when he plays open sicilian and
with the move d6 i think he's indicating
that we're going for it the only
question here is hikaru goes for the
trendy bishop b5 check or if he's
prepped something
in d4 and there we have the battle
between the seconds battle between the
ideas
and i'm very curious i think this is
going to be an excellent game another
game that i'm going to have to take a
look at is going to be this one
fabi with the black pieces playing the
italian but you know that he loves his
long games he doesn't want to draw today
as well he must still have the back of
his mind some idea that hey more than
ten percent is a significant number i
have to give myself my best odds of
winning this tournament that includes
beating a very weakened yonshishtov duda
a game that i'm not excited about
hopefully i'm wrong
is this one
wow yeah nepali chicken steamed rajab of
actually jan playing d4 so not going for
a berlin i was expecting a rookie one
berlin to be very honest with you guys
he's actually playing a catalan i want
to see what he brings in to the table
does ian because well catalan has has
been seen in this tournament quite quite
often and at the top level of chess
let's see if it brings him something to
play for if he's okay with a solid
position in a draw okay and by the way
turning your attention back to the game
of ikaro nakamura for a moment we do see
in the night or if the move bishop e3
and this invites one of the incredibly
sharp variations
of the english attack uh i don't even
know what the theory uh is these days
after knight g4 bishop g5 all i can tell
you is that this is a tavia position
that goes on a long long long long and
we haven't gone in these waters
for quite a number of uh tournaments so
but he didn't do it ali raised it after
bishop
it looks like he played e5
the alternative
and knight f3 wow no knight f3
what's the theoretical uh status
of knight f3 alejandro it's
supposed to be equal and rather
soft compared to the knight b3 lines
where
if you put the knight on b3 let me
explain the big difference here knight
b3 is by far the more popular move sure
knight b3 here and the idea is pretty
easy you put the screen here you castle
this way you go f3 g4 h4 h5 when you
kill the guy on the king's side now it's
easy if you put the knight on f3 you're
very easy well that's what the depot did
right right
if you put the knight on f3 you're
stifling
this idea of f3 g4 you just can't play
it right now there are some advantages
and disadvantages to having the knight
here the knight's already kind of
controlled but on the other hand it's
not on the way of some of your pieces on
b3 sometimes on b3 it's kind of a target
like if you put the knight on b3 and
you're wondering why don't i just castle
short slowly
it's because black eventually gets a5 a4
in against that knight right and you
never really want to play a4 yourself so
knight on f3 is a completely different
approach it's very positional
and it's rather slow this bishop is
trying to go to c4 and there will be a
battle over the d5 square now black has
more than one way to equalize in this
variation it really does come to how
full the equality is
and
which version of it do you want to play
because right now there's a couple of
ways of playing this position bishop e7
is of course there's nothing wrong with
this move but a lot of people say you
know what your move is bishop c4 right
let me stop it by playing a natural move
anyway instead of developing my bishops
or my knight a lot of people play the
move queen c7 first right just so that
this bishop doesn't get to the c4 square
immediately now there's also drawbacks
with it for example you'd rather develop
your king side uh if you go to knight c6
you allow bishop c4 anyway so you're
kind of stuck uh developing it with your
knight on d7 now the only thing you have
to avoid and one of the reasons this
knight is played to f3 is that if you do
play the move bishop p6
stopping bishop c4 you kind of straight
up right into knight g5 if you move the
bishop bishop c4 hits f7 so you can't
really put your bishop on e6 first the
idea of queen c7 is kind of
be a placeholder
to get h6
and then go bishop e6 right at some
point later in the game different ways
of handling this position i'm sure that
alireza is very well versed in this
position i'm pretty sure that i've seen
him play this with the black pieces i
just don't know if it was a classical
game if it was a series of rapids
theoretically the last time i checked
this with my students this was equal but
it did lead to playable positions for
both sides cool
um
the the one game that you kind of
intimated okay yan leading the
tournament he's gonna make a rather easy
short draw with t taymor in this line of
the catalan they're going for this very
topical line where you
mess up your queen side i want to say
for dynamic play we've seen
this in the tournament already
we'll keep an eye on that and a little
bit of a wrinkle knight to c3
by
um
again i i suspect this is uh theory as
well oh yeah of course yeah this is such
a topical line in this moment and the
more i've analyzed this variation the
more i'm wondering why
why black is playing this kind of
positions it does seem that it's razor
sharp edge into black
equalizing but why can play any move and
be
equal or better
i don't like this kind of positions
where one side has to find very precise
moves and the other one not so much and
this is what i gather from these
openings and these players are so well
prepared that rajabov is the type of
player that can play very precisely and
just draw the game but we've seen some
players fail to do it from this position
specifically i remember a game of wesley
saw with the white pieces against
uncertain yaniponnyachi
with the black pieces played very
recently in bucharest we had this type
of positions in that game
wesley actually took on a6 right like
most people do nowadays but this one is
also supposed to be slightly dangerous
uh pawn takes on b5 was played you don't
have a choice here rook takes a will be
on the board pretty soon bishop takes
knight takes b5 and the move here is
bishop d5 i know this much bishop d5
defends the pawn allows you to play c5
later and people have been looking here
at bishop f4 they've been looking at
bishop g5 they've been looking at rook
d1 all of them put some pressure on
black's position
still challenges black this variation is
is even unlike the one where you take on
a6 right material is even but your
control over e4 is crucial if you lose
control over e4 your entire queen side
might just fall apart if i get the move
e4 kick out the bishop and take on c4
you're just dead so it's important for
black to long term keep this in control
and you also want to play c5 as quickly
as possible you want to get rid of this
trunk pawn center
for white
rogue d1 is aimed against the move c5
and we have seen the move rook d1
plentifully bishop f4 bishop g5 i've
been tries as well i'm we're going to
have to wait and see what nepo brings
into this game against timor he has uh i
think there's a great choice of opening
for jan honestly he might get some
chances
to press if timor misplaced it and if
deeper plays that team replace it
properly you know what draws fine draws
good
and remember that they drew the first
time around in their round three
match-up uh a matchup that actually has
favored timor-rajava but he has one more
win the only win in between these two i
don't quite remember that game though
i'm gonna have to look it up
very good uh if i could play devil's
advocate for a moment just this i like
what you're saying there about bishop d5
and this big fight
for that central square e4
but if i could just ask
like a really gross question after
bishop takes a8 knight takes b5 can i
just play bishop takes f3 and if you
recapture with the bishop i'm not saying
you have to do that i'll go c6 and on my
very next turn play queen takes d4 just
absolutely
you know
blatantly ugly play for the draw
yeah the issue about these positions is
that even though
i mean you're not losing or anything but
no oh you're not up a pawn right right
you could take on a3 right but that's
suicidal at that point with the two
bishops the two bishops and a past pawn
the bomb was on b2 you might have some
chances blockade on d5 i don't know
right with a passport on a3 you just
don't want to do that right and if you
take on d4 and i take c4 it feels that
you didn't win the pawn
and you've got the two bishops as a
disadvantage for free again is this the
lost no are most people watching this
show are going to convert this 100 of
the time
no no
is y'all going to convert it 100 of the
time also no but you have pretty good
chances
you just don't want to be on the back
foot with black this early that's why uh
after knight to xb5 i fully expect them
with bishop d5 unless timor has some
sort of novelty here i know that move c5
was tried
but it was insufficient last time i
checked it
uh so i still expect bishop d5 to be the
the move that is played because it's
theory approved okay and dorsa what uh
game has caught your attention um well
i uh there i did see a very very
interesting rue lopez being played i
think that was the richard draper
dingley run game all right yes that's
our
number one seed coming into the
tournament dingler in and for his fans
so very excited for him as he did win in
round nine his first
victory after nine rounds the number one
seed nobody
uh anticipated that he would have such a
difficult time and this what for this
bishop
um c5
oh bishop to g5 that's
unusual for me to see that so early is
white h7h6
richie doing something a little bit uh
off the beaten path with this very early
pin
bishop on h4 go ahead this is a very
interesting game because
most of my students are in the range of
like 1500 to like 2 000. so i always
tell them like pins are so uncomfortable
you want to play for center you want to
make sure you have central control
that's what white has and i always
advocate for like pins are a little um
interesting in the sense that you want
to make sure that it kind of bothers the
opponents it kind of cripples a little
it kind of begs the question are you
going to take or you're not going to
take that tension yeah so i think that
most of our viewers would find that's
interesting to see that there are like
so many different pins and so many ideas
with d4 and
yeah this is a very um
comfortable game for me right now okay
well indeed i have to tell you that for
me personally
i hate being in a pins i really do
it really yeah it really uh throws me
off kilter so to speak and so i really
look forward to breaking the pins or you
know blockading now the problem with
this bishop on h4 is
obviously my bishop is now on a7 it's
not on e7 where i can break the pin
and
literally i have no other way of
breaking the pin other than by playing
the move g7 g5 maybe driving the bishop
back to g3 now then it could go on the
other foot like the bishop on g3
is no great shakes it's not like it has
a great view of the board right what
would black do with its king if it goes
g5 precisely that's the that's the
problem you go for example g uh let's
say after bishop let's just put a move
on the board knight d2 for for for the
moment g5 bishop g3 and then we'll just
put queen e7 that's this kind of
flexible thing
so now as black we've got a problem
because we played g5 so well we kind of
pushed our pawn shield over on the king
side forward we're probably not hiding
our king over there but then you look on
the other side of the board and you say
well wait a minute
we played b7 b5 as well it's not like we
really want to hide our king over on the
queen site so what do we do we just stay
in the middle with our king so in a
sense black has a real problem he
doesn't know where he's going to put his
king
but let's flip it board and say okay how
about you white where are you going to
put your king you go wait a minute you
know like the king side's nice and safe
wait a minute are we so sure
that it's nice and safe our opponents
already got a flank attack going with g5
and h6 maybe we have to be worried that
rook g8 and h5 might disturb us so
uh
that's what i mean when i'm thinking a
double-edged game
both what does double edge mean means
that you have your problems i got my
problem
and whoever resolves them best wins
and by the way bishop c5a7 is a rare
bird
uh
the idea after c3 is that you're
angling for d4 you're not there yet
uh
so lots of times you play bishop b7 and
you wonder after d4 should i put my
bishop back on b6 and put it back on a7
bishop a7
has been played according to our
database like
twice
i mean that's
that's
shocking for uh rui lopez
that uh normally we got millions of
games yeah
so uh the players are investigating a
relatively rare line alejandro
and it's fascinating to see this italian
battles right you get to this position
do you play a6b5 h6 g5 right and it
might not even be an italian but you
have the italian type of ideas
and they all kind of mushed together
right right
another
italian that we have today i'm gonna
check it out because it has a lot of
elements from different spaces
but the positioning is unique
funny enough so we have this italian
between young staff duda and fabiano
corona we've never seen this position
before ever
somehow
this new knight bd2 is actually a
novelty oh wow now that being said you
might think that this structure is
familiar right and you might think well
i've seen this in this tournament before
many times right many times but
specifically like this
and i was thinking about this game this
is alireza ferrugia timo rajabo from a
couple rounds ago the marathon game that
ended with a king h4 rook h1 king g5
repetition right that started stemmed
from this variation and you can see the
structural similarities right right this
is this game this is the favi game
pretty much the same thing couple little
differences the knights on h5 there's no
pawn on h6 subtleties that the players
analyze to try to learn not just from
themselves but from the opponents the
candidates usually brings incredibly
important theoretical knowledge to the
players and they adapt accordingly
throughout and also fabi might be
thinking i remember this position and
there are some games of chess that are
just so engraved in your memory because
they were either so brilliant they're so
painful
and i think that fabi remembers this one
very well he was white against the
certain alexander grizzchuk here in st
louis i want to say it was a san luis
rabbit and blitz but i'm going to have
to check that out and i just remember
how that game ended
now check out this bishop on a7 it's
this bishop such a pretty one they got
the from this position eventually they
got to this one where the bishop on a7
is still
attacking this king on g1 and i remember
this visual move where five just puts
his queen on g3 and grishok went
king eight shade in severe severe time
pressure he goes king h8 and fabio
didn't have as much time pressure right
he was already down on the clock but not
seconds left the way chris chuck was and
horror of horus he realizes there is no
way to prevent
knight f3 check
pawn takes pawn takes and then one of
the rooks coming to the g-file
he just completely stuck on the king
side see how they get man the rook b2
knight f3 check
can't do anything takes take that takes
on f3 is actually dubious because rook
h7 was made in 10. okay rook fb won but
no matter rook g7 wins the queen destroy
demolished fabiano caruana with the
black pieces
bobby might be thinking hey that was a
good idea
why don't i do that and here we have it
he's using that recipe that chris
brought against him against duda so we
are having this fight of ideas duda took
some time with diabetes ii and now
players are on their own
okay just continuing the thought there
you see the knight on h i see the knight
on h5 that's a visual i think it's going
to f4 go ahead put the knight on f4 how
would the play proceed
i think the move knight f4 is always a
useful move right the only question is
how early do you want to play it okay
the only reason that sometimes knight f4
is delayed is that after the logical
move knight f1 you don't know if you
want to allow the capture so quickly
okay now you might be thinking isn't
that completely fine that's true another
reason though is that when this bishop
comes to e3 and i capture it
sometimes taking on e3 with the pawn
gets a tempo and there's another
argument that the knight on f4 move
isn't going anywhere and then it's more
useful to bring the queen first first
whether it be e8 g6 or f6 directly
that's up to 5e but those would be the
three moves i'm looking at queen e8
bring it to g6 queen f6 to target more
things on the f file or you know what
bring the knight directly to f4 i think
they're all viable it's just at this
point what we call a bit of a matter of
style okay
thank you for that we do have more moves
in the game of yon
in that position where you alejandro was
saying that you're aware
with bishop to d5 he played it
yes
dorset what do you think
we got some more moves after bishop d5
the bishop came out and and what
alejandro was saying is black is
aspiring for c fight yes
which is exactly what he said is kind of
pushing you to
oh
whoa wait a minute no way how could
bishop f4
be a novelty no no bishop b3 the the
move on the game bishop b3 is a novelty
oh
okay because that seemed like such a
natural move to me you developed with a
gain of a tempo i can understand why you
could also
so dorset if you're sitting there saying
my opponent's going to play c5
can't i stop him would you have
considered the move bishop e3 uh i mean
it it's logical but i also block my own
potential for pawn e4 so exactly
he played bishop f5 and timor did get on
with his business which was to trade off
his double pawns takes i like this move
a lot queen a5
um
developing inter-mezzo yeah
uh gaining a a tempo against the knight
on b5 did not knight drop back the queen
captured
and then the bishop decided you know
what
this diagonal is not as attractive to me
as this diagonal so he played bishop e3
i think we're caught up with the players
this is still theory alejandro the movie
bishop e3 is new and that's why timor is
the one spending some time in this
position he has a bunch of options on
where to put the queen my engine is not
the strongest but it's not very
impressed by this move it says queen a5
or queen c7 is still equal now my
experience playing this positions online
and the little bit of studying that i've
done on it is that again white can play
anything including bishop e3 and black
has to respond more or less precisely
uh for example what would be your more
natural move for that queen queen a5
queen c7 both of those move may
make uh
a5 and here i'm going to use my pressure
yes on c4 to try to get you okay to take
with the pawn okay if you take with the
pawn it's kind of strategical disaster
no i don't like no he goes though no me
gusta why you get a lot of weak dark
squares the pawns are stuck d5 is weak
you always want to take back with the
knight correct so knight takes knight
takes and now i can do this right now
because if i take on c4 yeah you win
upon you once upon congratulations but
this is so ugly right that i'm gonna end
up getting one of them back you're not
proud i'm not very proud of this win of
a pawn no so
for a while
uh black is gonna have to be careful
that when white takes on d5 yeah i
either take with the knight because i
can attack something or my pawn on c4 is
already defended right and this goes on
for a few moves you can play bishop d4
for example to renew the threat you
could play rook c1 to have this as a
stronger thread down the line you could
play you could even take immediately
and then retreat and then put the rook
on c1 and start pressuring c4 again all
of these variations
very very close to equality
but white is the one that's still
putting a couple of ideas and a couple
of pressure points on timor javo so he's
found a move that's taking his opponent
completely out of book
timor does not expect the move bishop e3
hasn't looked at it there's too many
moves to look at in this position to
consider all of them it's just too wide
to consider all of white's moves so he's
on his own he needs to fully equalize
still he should be on the verge of it he
i'm sure has looked at this variation
extensively
and what i just explained he knows
his hand
so i expect them to still be within the
reaches of equality but i also love
nepo's prep riskless
never going to lose this with white no
every blue moon you win right
um
uh alejandro help me out here uh i read
an article on the chess-based website
that nepo has a super computer
lurking in the background that the
russians have provided for him
and that
that was why the novelty of knight h4
that
um
fabi prepped was such a good one because
the super computer would not have looked
at it it wasn't its top list of moves
uh so
what what's the story on the super
computer that's helping nepo i haven't
fully read i've heard of the article
that you're mentioning and i know what
you're talking about that the russians
have actually provided an actual super
computer see we we use this term very
loosely in the chess world right the
term supercomputer is actually a
specific term
for machines that are not commercial
they're not for everybody they're out
there in the
physics world in the astronomy world
they're actually solving
really really tough equations we have
really good computers right in the chat
they're not super computers but they're
really really really good they're really
expensive anyway and they do
cost dozens of thousands
of dollars right
you know i'll be looking at computers
for like fifty sixty thousand dollars
that these people are using
what i heard was that
nepo had an actual super computer wow
like one of those actual things they
allowed him to use it for a little bit
that's what i heard that's what i read
it's all rumors as far as i'm concerned
right so i don't really know
does this actually make a difference
it's kind of hard to tell
the engines are playing so well right
now that it's more important for us to
be able to parse the information
properly
the problem is that the stronger the
engines get
the more they think everything is zero
zero
because for them they can already see to
the end of the game what is the
difference right if you have to find 30
moves in a row as black
to
reach
a theoretically
drawn pawn end game if the engine saw
that far
it doesn't care
it's going to find them it's going to
tell you it's objectively a draw
but is that the path that you want to
take and that's where the uh that's
where having good seconds comes in
having people that can parse that
information properly
and be able to determine this is
actually humanly dangerous the way
knight h4
was humanly dangerous in that petrov
game so
yes of course it's very important to
have extremely powerful computers
however i think that they do hit a bit
of a ceiling as what how much they can
tell us they will find some interesting
ideas here and there that more normal
computers can't find but it's not that
common now
staying on the topic of engines how
realistic do you think it is to
finally have you know that perfect
engine that finds the beautiful balance
between practical human chess and
those super great moves do you think
that's
realistic in the foreseeable future yeah
i i do i see that the chess engines of
today not only are they incredible
engines at calculating but
that there are actual software that you
can use to
make them more human that they you they
can challenge you to play
certain positions that they're an
incredible training tool now when i was
growing up the engines really were
were nice and fun and strong
but
what they've done in the meanwhile is
absolutely fantastic that they've grown
exponentially and um
in terms of commercial engines alejandro
do you yourself
as a chess coach have a favorite do you
think
one engine does something that another
engine does
worse or better
i think that entrants are actually quite
interesting and they have all these
flavors at the end of the day if you're
analyzing casually
if you're watching this show it doesn't
really matter
what you put in i mean your engine is
going to be wrong it's just the way it
is because somebody out there has a
stronger engine right uh when it comes
to actual software i think by far the
underway the most popular one is
stockfish it's free it's easy to install
and it's extremely strong it's arguably
the strongest engine that you can do and
it runs smoothly there are other engines
like lila that add to the game
they're a little bit in my opinion more
difficult to interpret i have had some
arguments against leela like on certain
positions like are you sure are you sure
engine that you really want to go down
this path but there are some others
where lila proposes an idea that's so
interesting and so unexpected that it
actually beats out stockfish this
usually turns out being long-term plans
long-term ideas danger of the king all
these kind of things lila tends to see
better and this might be very vague
terms but it's difficult for an engine
to evaluate a pawn structure 20 moves
down the road
that's not how a lot of engines think
now
there's a lot of different engines out
there there's
traditionally if we talk about engines
of the past or even current engines
ripka shredder sharks
uh fruit there's a lot of fruits yeah
fritz to a certain extent
the engine of the past uh that
bring their own kind of ideas they bring
their own flavors they have their own
evaluation system for certain openings
and they have their own weights and it's
not so clear which one is better than
the other or the highest level they all
crush us right right so what's the
difference right uh they all crush us
without a second thought
so it really comes down to which engine
you adjust yourself the best and i think
everybody has their own little flavor
profile at the very top
and
that is more of an individual thing
for most i think 99 of players stockfish
whatever the latest is
go forward good good enough how about
you dorset do you
have your own
chess engine favorite or you just think
they're all good see uh being a part of
slew testing for the past five years
my tail is kind of
linked to alejandro's tale so whatever
he gets for the team i got it
right so we've we've looked into leela
stockfish we have very strong computers
i'm very sad to part ways with them oh
oh oh oh one of the cons of graduating i
guess look at this you'll be going to
christian's
uh
chess academy but what you gotta
[Laughter]
uh by the way not
maybe you're right alejandro we've just
seen the move bishop e3
to d2 by yon
i'm not going to say it proposes a draw
because of course it doesn't but if we
do see the move queen a5 for example you
kind of want to avoid knight takes and
be forced to recapture the queen but if
we do see
uh bishop c5 it is a kind of intimation
that there might be a repetition citing
so just keep in mind that bishop d2 on
the board but it's not it's not a
repetition right it's not i mean queen
c5
here i take on d5 what do you take back
with
let's take pawn first
remember that when the knight was on d5
and my bishop was on f4 as well as e3 as
well as c3 the knight
hits the bishop right that's a tempo no
it does not now it does not so i can
play something along the lines of rook
c1 even knight e5 and that this pawn is
it's dead yeah no you're absolutely
right i apologize bishop d2
um
actually comes with a threat yeah
actually
okay good apologies for that my bad uh
just going to check with the
back in with the game between hikaru
and ali reza after the move knight f3 we
were talking about queen c7 as a way of
delaying white's desired bishop to c4 he
didn't do that he said you know what if
you want to put your bishop on c4
go for it
bishop c4 bishop e6
and now i'm trying to remember a game i
think it was between mvl and nepo
alejandro will help me out here it was a
game that uh
nvl needed to win in the last round sing
phil kapoor syncfield 2017
right something like that yeah
and then i i don't know if this is
exactly there was no no
definitely not the same position no okay
and a knight d5 on the board knight d5
by the way comes with an explosive
threat bishop b6 and knight c7 would be
a winning threat so knight d5 you know
treat it seriously
we still i'm sure we are but are we
what's the theory on this particular
position aleandro we have some important
games that have been played in this
position check it out sergey karjakin
played this with the white pieces
against jan nepomniacci all the way back
in 2012. ten years ago it's been a
decade but we're still debating this
position another game that i have to
mention because you mentioned that great
name maxime vasherla graf what an expert
he is with the night of not only with
black but as he mentioned in that game
in 2017 beating nepo to take the sing
field cup he did that with the white
pieces and remember he is going to be
joining us later at 10 30 a.m here
central mvl will be joining our show so
he's going to be live
i didn't know that that's great he's
going to be explaining this one for us
now after knight d5 both of those games
follow with the correct move rook c8
you're not afraid of bishop b6 because
the rook here covers the c7 square and
after queen d7 you're not worried the
black oh sorry that white is going to
take all of this tempo just to ruin your
structure that's a very typical sveshnik
of sicilian type of position in which if
you can break with f5 early it's no
problem the bishop is actually a little
bit misplaced not a weak bishop just
misplaced on b6 so 95 rook c8 is
considered to be the correct move in
this position i don't know if there's
another correct move in this position at
all to be completely fair with you
because bishop e6 is such a big threat
and you are not well prepared to take on
d5 in this position for example if you
take with the knight pawn takes just
wins a piece that's kind of clear and if
you take with the bishop then i take
with the bishop you take uh you could
throw in this check but i have bishop d2
and if you take with the knight again
you're not forcing me to recapture with
the pawn and this is usually what black
wants to do force white to recapture
with the pawn on d5 instead i get to
take with the queen and establish my
dominance over the light squares in the
center you're going to follow it up with
short or even long castle and black is
not going to have an active plan ever so
after the move 95 rook c8 is the
recommended move by the engine it is the
move that has been played at the top
level of chaffs twice it is also the
move i expect alireza to play even
though both sides are taking their sweet
time to get to this position i see an
hour 40 for hikaru an hour 45 for furusa
they're not blasting through the opening
theory the way that they did in their
first uh bout in the first half of the
candidates remember that already brought
this beautiful nimsoo indian prep right
higher was blitzing out got stuck
and then figured it out over the board
yeah that's a great stuff between these
two players so we see there their only
game so far in classical chess was that
draw that they had about a week ago
wow
yeah that was a that was an amazing
piece of what we would call a save by
hikaru because he really walked into
this great preparation by
by ali reza it almost seemed
like uh alireza got an advantage all the
way through the ending
it goes from the opening to advantageous
ending uh by great prep but
ikaru man he just uh
calculated his way to a draw i wanted to
bring your attention to the game that
you liked
right here and i was thinking to myself
uh you know like how are you going to
break this pin g7 g5 and where do you
put the king well
richard just said look
you're going to attack me on the king's
side go for it you know if you want to
play g5 i'm going to put my king in
harm's way
ending oops excuse me that went a little
bit
digler in said okay
first of all
it's this bishop on a b3 that i really
don't like i want this guy
uh
to get out of dodge bishop c
then the move a c7 c5 so i'm going to
take a little bit more firmer control
over the d4 square make it a little bit
more difficult for you to play d4
knight d2
g5
bishop g3 ah knight h5 this is and
wonderful
i'm gonna poke you a little on the queen
side a6 b5 knight f5 okay let's take it
minutes let's go h6 g5 knight h5 it's uh
but
as a chess teacher
don't you tell your students uh so
oftentimes
especially with lower class players uh
class c b
they get enamored they love their queen
and they're moving their queen
everywhere or they get enamored with
their bishops
also sometimes what happens to players
is they like pushing their pawns they do
that
yeah right like and suddenly they start
so just a second you've got eight pawns
and dinglerin has pushed seven out of
eight
like and don't you as a chess coach say
to your
uh
you know like
guys take it easy relax don't don't
don't move all your pawns
and uh this is
that i i don't know
is this something we've seen before
alejandro is this uh no no no no no no
it's some kind of deep prep by uh
by ding
we got d6 he got all of these moves in
they're all very sharp right you should
throw this in i've been told knight h5
is a novelty but i mean we're so far
from the throes of actual theory that it
doesn't really matter
whoa was definitely not the novelty uh
knight h5
in this position is actually deviating
from here uh we got c5 in this position
okay it's not a relevant game so we
can't really consider it knight h5 leads
to a position that ding has for sure
seen and this is the most relevant part
right how do i know that he's seen it
because you don't play knight h5
under eight minutes right for the
entirety of the game you play you blitz
knight h5 because you know it and we
have such a really weird crazy position
already the king as you mentioned can't
castle anywhere but this king it's also
feeling the pressure a little bit the
black is coming on this way now the
usual way i would think that black
playing on the king side here has to be
met with a move a break on the other
side of the board i think the move a4
screams to be played for me mm-hmm
you want to see if black really wants to
close things down because it might open
up your c file it might allow you to get
some light squares i would think a4 is
the most natural move here for white
knight takes g3 not really a threat now
let's see why for example a4 knight
takes pawn things if you try to kill me
immediately
with things like h5 yeah i am in time to
take on b5 and survive but it becomes a
little sharp i can tell you this because
i have an engine right when you look at
this as a human and your opponent has
spent zero time right sometimes you are
you worry that if i take here the guy
goes h4 that i actually get mated you
might be done i might be done right yeah
it might be game over you know that all
these classics there's like 1800
games where they take and they go rook
h1 and there's like a queen there they
distract the knight and you can't
prevent checkmate and that's the reason
we're playing chess today right those
inspiring games
they didn't have engines right they
didn't care if the attack worked or not
i mean it was one of many
in this game it's a candidate's
tournament richer with white your
opponent is blitzing all of this out and
you see the move knight h5
your mind immediately thinks
am i getting mated here right and that's
what he's going to have to figure out
there are a couple of like more um
sedate sedate ways of playing right but
i think that if you want to challenge
black setup you got to go with the move
a4
what do you feel when you're playing
against opponent
and they're just snapping out the moves
and you can see like uh richard
that your king is in danger
how do you deal with that kind of
pressure
that's like for me looking at the
specific game i was thinking
why did white castle too early because
you know black is certainly not planning
to castle anytime soon so why would i
castle to kind of like my king has a red
flag hello i'm over here right yeah so
um unless after castle white could
comfortably open up center yeah i don't
know if uh
i would want a castle too early on
right but
well
also what i'm really saying is
because dingler in is playing so quickly
you almost feel like you're falling into
some kind of trap
that your opponent has
the homework and and you know you're
supposed to lose in a very nice fashion
you might just follow while you mention
trap um i recently re-watched all the
pirates of caribbean because my friend
at disney plaza i'm like you know much
less binge them all
and you can't think of a better way to
spend a week yourself go on and there
was like one of these like the they're
like running in the jungle and there's
this like nice trap that they go in and
it gives them a whoosh takes them all up
in the tree this kind of feels like
that's that it's gonna do that whoosh
take up on the tree and you are caught
in a net yeah yeah so this whole uh idea
again alejandro saying
look uh i've got to meet this attack on
the king side with some kind of counter
play now i can play for uh d4 an attack
in the center or as he said
a2 a4 in his mind are screaming to be
played you know this knight's a little
bit offside so it lends itself to
an attractive attack so a4 but then just
again i'm just quoting uh alejandro here
is that
you start to worry that wait a minute
my opponent's been playing snap snap
and
that's sorry
you know this bishop is like eyeballing
this long diagonal so if i i make a bad
move this is a terrible move to take you
start to think well
wait wait a minute this bishop is going
to be
you know like eyeballing my king and if
i
that these are the types of checkmate
that alejandro oh scary is saying you
know from the 18 let's do it with style
i agree agreed uh let's do it with style
and sacrifice the queen so we see a lot
of games from the 1800s where thanks to
this bishop controlling the g1 square we
have a check made so these are the types
of things that richard is considering
what's the time
uh i believe that dingley wren has about
yeah dingle loren is a
hour 52 minutes upwards is hour 24. so
he spent about like 35 minutes of his
time huge difference
and for ding loren i mean he was in the
cellar he was really at the bottom of
the cross table
one win just one win he jumped into a
tie for third
four and a half points if he puts back
back-to-back wins together
it's remarkable and he will be beating
richard rapport who's currently in a tie
for fifth through ninth place at four
points so dingle ring could do himself a
great deal of good yeah
today i mean like i mean he's had such a
bad start
that it's hard to believe with just two
back-to-back wins that he he would
suddenly be
in contention maybe that's being uh too
much but okay quick question please
after knight takes bishop we never
really talked about what if you know
pawn f takes it it feels very suicidal
in the sense that that bishop is still
yes that that amish that a7 bishop is
quite open right but it also opens up
the f1 rook so how do you feel about
this i like it i seriously
often times
the rule
the principle i should say the principle
is captured towards the center so h2
takes g3
is by far and away
the move that we consider first always
capture towards always capture
but sometimes
the dynamics of a specific position
might be that look
this pawn structure actually offers my
king better protection
and it's that simple and
even though i'm not capturing towards
the center my king is a little bit
better protected and as you just
mentioned
it's not like hey i'm suddenly going to
checkmate you down the f line but then
the rook is open so
the dynamic
play that you get for
having compromised your pawn is worth it
and i like f2
takes g3 many many times in the sicilian
your white newcastle queenside
you've got a bishop on b3 that guy
captures your bishop now a2 takes b3 is
the normal response everybody plays but
then you start thinking wait a minute if
i capture with the c pawn capturing away
from the center my king's really really
safe so sometimes you see this
contrarian c2 takes b3 and i like your
suggestion very nicely yeah the long
castle thing i i love playing scotch
when i was a kid i watched this part of
having his like scotch
face and i loved it and i played it and
i still do sometimes and for the like
there is a specific lines with long
castle in bishop c5 knight b3 that i've
had a lot of experience when somehow
like bishop comes to e6 takes on b3 and
you can take back with the c and you
just put your king b1 a1 you say bye bye
and you start f3 g4 push king's like go
go go go go yeah it feels really it felt
like very sicilian-wise well you're
saying it i was having that little deja
vu right but at the end of the day what
you really appreciate as your kings
tucked away the more pawns around it the
happiest exactly exactly the more pawns
and happier it is uh we'll keep an eye
on this game with you do you have a move
sorry
they played
a3
yeah
wow
that is really
8283 i've
maybe maybe it's a coffee
three more coffees double espresso
please
a3
that is so slow is it just trying to
stop b4 or set up b4 or
was it trying to go a4 and it just
stopped middle of the way oops
uh i'm gonna have to bring in you know
higher intelligence here uh
a2 a3 alejandro was that on the top of
the computer's hit list
uh not in the top
actually i'm wondering
how do you put it that way it's not in
the top three this one goes up to five
let me see if i remember how to
change the settings yeah here
lines all the way up to
five uh i don't know
not in the top five no i mean it's not
the strongest engine but it was
definitely not in the top five of this
one i'm gonna go backwards wow
a3
i don't get it i mean you really want to
go b4
right i feel you don't right like
normally in this structure like this
this is a good break right b4 is a good
break the only thing is that in this
particular version
this bishop
loves that the b4 break exists
black doesn't have to hurry and take
because then white takes with the a pawn
that's the whole point of a3 and then
you open up your rook you're going to be
happy about the morse on the center what
i'm worried about is that if i play b4
and just move my knight you don't want
to take on c5 i don't think right as
long as e5 is not hanging d takes e5 is
satisfactory but also i think bishop
takes c5 is going to be okay it all
really hinges on whether you can play d4
or not
it feels a bit slow to me yeah sir so
slow actually the end just want to
encourage you to play b4 how do they do
that they do root b8 and they say you
don't do anything special i'll go either
b4 or c4 myself take advantage of the
fact that the rook is on the b8 square
so the only logical move would be
b4 b4 but after taking you throw this
move in
i gotta take with the h pawn on this
version because yes
otherwise it's a discovery check and you
go here the engines think no problem's
still equal
perhaps a little bit better for black
but not very much
i just don't i just don't understand
why you're allowing my bishop to
to reign supreme
one day i'll get in g4 h5h4 it might not
be the soonest right but one day i'm
gonna do that i mean the moment i cover
h4 or i start with the move h5 h4 first
i'll get there right whereas white on
the other hand has given up the pair of
bishops
and needs something in return i just
don't know
what that in return
is
i'm baffled i'm baffled by the move a3
it's not the move i wanted to play it's
a very richy move he comes up with this
new concept these new ways of seeing the
position of seeing the structure of
seeing how the game can change
not
my understanding but it is what it is
let's see if it pays up for richie he's
a very creative player i know that
dingley red might have trouble dealing
with it let's take a look at another
game that is just so important for us
guys it's just so important whoa
we have only a couple of moves after uh
bishop d2 this bishop on d5 is
threatened we analyzed that timor just
moved it back right get out of the way
this is a very logical move and
therefore it was considered by team nepu
instantly replied the move knight d1
actually it's a pretty logical retreat
the knight on e3 attacks the pawn on c4
i'm gonna be honest with you guys
queen c5 is already a mistake according
to the engine i'm not sure if it's a
real mistake or it's uh slowly slightly
slipping from
equality but i think white's position
just plays itself 93 attacks that pawn
black defense said why don't i just
attack it again exactly and this is why
i was doing a dvd series and a video
series for limitless chess it was i was
trying to finish up a repertoire against
d4 okay and i was recommending the neo
vienna this d4 knight f6 c4 e6 quick d5
and taking one c4
the thing is i still needed something as
a catalan and since this was so
fashionable i saw it plentifully and i
just i just couldn't recommend these
positions they were theoretically fine
at the 2700 level
but
it felt always like you were in a knife
set to actually equalizing and you're
never never better with black that
doesn't sound like the ideal amateur
repertoire
no who wants that who wants that and
even at this level
i don't feel that people are equalizing
it so easily no nepo lost to wesley
jan i think it's already much better
against timor he's already played rookie
one all these moves
natural natural i'm taking this pawn
it's it's not a if or maybe you don't
move that pawn i will take it it is free
you have to defend it but what are you
defended with
okay bishop d5 but this is exactly what
we were talking about right we just went
back to a8 and he just went back to it
and if i take
you have to take with the knight
otherwise your position
terrible if you think with the pawn why
got everything terrible you might
survive but why got everything if you
take with the knight and i go knight e5
using the fact that tactics allow me to
play this move there's no night before
because bishop takes there's no
discoveries with the knight anywhere
i'm attacking your pawn
i have the pair of bishops
i have the initiative
why is black so happy about this
position
that night on b8 is just so sad it
hasn't moved i know a few months ago i
was thinking you know if that knight
could get to b3 black's problems would
be solved but i think that's i have a
better shot at winning presidency than
that is getting to b3
true that uh it's a long way to
temporary you got to go c6 d4 v3 um
no this looks like
nepo has
more or less gotten the ideal opening
game one where he can play risk-free
for two results yep nice well done
um dorsal were you
with me on this one we wanted to ask
alejandro after the move a3 by richard
a move we kind of things too slow you're
not
snapping out you're not making black's
life difficult what if black just threw
down the gauntlet
took on g3 and
i like your f2 takes g3 by the way one
more time thank you but in case of h2
takes g3 what if black said i'm here to
play for checkmate is that
not frightening alejandro oh everything
is frightening here for
for what you're saying richard i mean
i'm saying he's played a3 so he said do
your worst and i go okay
i'll try this is pretty bad guys
you have to go before just to make sense
of this but at this wandering you're
still wondering if you're gonna get
mated like 18th century style right
right
i'm not even sure if it doesn't work
thanks like i mean the engine wants to
go knight c6 okay but i'm i'm trying to
figure out why h4 doesn't work h4
doesn't work because you still have the
move g4
richie is playing this nice hatch i
don't like it okay i don't like any of
this for white but for ding lyrin i mean
his heart just kind of
skipped a beat like hey you know like
opportunity knocking on the door perhaps
yeah perhaps the real reason that you
the engine doesn't want to take on g3
immediately remember they like taking on
g3 when it forces the issue and here you
might still since before still not on
the board you might take with the f-pawn
fair
you hide the king on h1 and you have the
open rook still says it's equal both
sides with chances but i think the
engine is trying to force you to go
before to force you to take with the h
pawn gotcha any any chance that black
has enough time again in a
very comfortable world to go upon f6
knight g7 punish five punish four or is
that too dreamy
i think you just want to take advantage
of the exact position so you want to
retreat the knight somewhere and pushed
upon yeah and it is dangerous in this
kind of positions because the bishop is
so dead right right uh the issue i think
is that white will eventually play b4 a4
and i have the feeling that it's just
going to take you too long
without that much effect to get the
pawns rolling i think that you give
yourself a target
on g3 that can't move as easily as a
bishop and then you push the pawns also
this knight is not particularly good
even if you got all the way to e6 it's
not
that good it's okay so just chop the
bishop i think is uh is what i would do
whether i do it right now or a little
bit later i think that's what dean loren
is considering at the moment
uh speaking of a
bishop on a7 this kind of guided missile
kind of a bishop looking towards white's
king on g1 i returned to the game
between duda and fabi when we left it we
just left it at this position where i
was saying
well you played knight h5 for a reason
let's jump and put it on that wonderful
f4 square alejandro was saying well you
could also
uh pre
uh move
you could also get in the queen e8 queen
g6 before you played knight f4 or you
could play queen f6 knight f4 aliyah um
fabi went for knight f4 immediately
queen f6
that night
was threatening to capture a pawn on h3
with a check and that would
uncover the knight on f3 i guess
duda did not like the move knight h2 he
captured and then
fabi recaptured in order to keep the
half open f-file
i mean i'm sitting here thinking to
myself boy i like black's position this
bishop
is really really powerful maybe on a
good day i'm going to triple
up and then go
rook g6 that would be very pretty
it's going to be a
a killing attack
queen went to b3 okay i got that part
uh hitting the pawn on e6 in my mind
there's two ways of defending one would
be to play knight to d8 and the other is
the move chosen which was rook f6
b5 wow and we're up to date with the
players and
this position
is really rather sharp
and let's just take a look at their
head-to-head lifetime scorers
so there was a draw earlier in the
tournament but doodle has never managed
to beat
bobby bobby has beaten duda twice and
there has been a total of four draws so
six games a nice score for fabby for
sure
and uh there is a a cute little queen
trap
on the board here
i'm just saying that if you go knight a5
and maybe it's a good move maybe it's a
bad move and if you go aha gotcha queen
b4 i can turn the tables
with bishop c5 oh yes
sort of okay that the game could still
continue after queen takes a6 but it did
uh immediately flash
uh that there are some tricks one thing
i think you want to avoid as white
pardon me as black is you don't want
this this is yeah you there's no reason
to open up the a file and get yourself
all in a pin like this for example to my
mode be like a strategic disaster i
agree this is just so
uncomfortable so you don't take so much
questions no please after this rook f6
yes um
this is it feels like there might be an
attack coming up so recap 6v5
how do you feel about rook g6
is that a possibility oh definitely
because your r
i mean come on
if it's your turn queen takes f3 i
resign
uh i guess i'm going to i can't move the
knight because f2 is hanging so i guess
i'm forced to defend
the knight with knight to f2 now
that
oh that's so pretty but i was trying to
calculate some potential takes like i
was thinking okay you know what let's
just take the knight take the knight
queen takes e6 maybe i'm i'm still not
done thinking about it but oh my gosh
that's a that's a devil guys i i need to
stop you when you're getting things like
that but night look at knight one h2
right yeah sure okay don't you have
queen g3 there yeah i just did i played
it
no no on the other oh okay but this one
also doesn't look too good for for a
wide right queen f3 queen e6 i feel like
black's doing great
yeah king h8 you're threatening mate
with queen takes
uh f2 and queen takes g2 you take the
rook
oops
i'm in time and i've got the queen as
well it's good enough so
rook
g6
uh doris has moved rook g6 threatening
this queen takes thanks to the pin
pardon me
threatening this queen takes f3
am i supposed to move my king alejandro
the engine says king h1 is the best move
in the position okay
well the inclusion of those two moves
has to be favorable for black
not so clear actually
not so clear bishop takes f2s on
i can
i i i
i can see opportunity here for black
people um
by the way uh
sorry um
alejandro did the computer like rook f6
because there was also the move knight
d8 i assume
fabi didn't want to see d4 he he
essentially forced duda to play b5
and uh
whether it's rook g6 now or maybe on the
next move uh
my first feeling is
i like fabi's position a lot
yeah that was my first feeling too
unfortunately i run it through an engine
and the cold-blooded the engine is just
much better
what yeah much better get out not even
close rook g6 is a move
but after king h1 you still have to
solve the issue of the knight okay you
could put it on d8 but the main crux of
the position is that at some point i'm
going to go a2 or d4 it doesn't matter
you kill the activity of the bishop here
okay let's start at d4
and i will eventually take on a6 right i
will eventually play queen c4 and target
something bishop b6 will eventually run
to a5
so how do you keep your queen side
together where's the knight going okay
so let's suppose i try to close the
queen side with a6 a5 very good a6 a5
and uh now i focus on the other side of
the board
i think the main problem for favi's
position yeah is going to be his minor
pieces uh the engine wants to go queen
c4 or something like that i think rookie
2 also makes sense just to hold on to
the f2 pawn right knight h2 knight h2 g4
is also being an idea in many positions
i think at the end of the day the
problem is that because this bishop is
here right locked and this knight is so
far away from the action right that one
day i'm going to be able to play rookie
2 knight h2 g3
force you back
and if i force you back all of these
moves that you made on the king side
they look kind of silly because your
rook is going to be stuck on g6 whereas
i can start pushing pawns or playing 93
c4 depending on where my knight is
against black's position when i looked
at this
i thought fabi was okay
yeah i think and i looked at this
position they think black's okay that
would be my first instinct that's a gm
black has their chances i'm sure that
white has their chances and we just kind
of
uh play chess the engines hate black's
position wow i think it's a nearly plus
one advantage they just think that all
of this
is a smoke screen that there's no real
threats
and then you have a couple of accurate
moves to bounce back the attack repel
the attack and the white's going to be
better i don't know if either one of
these players is looking at the position
like that
but i can bet you that
white is going to end up making some
very natural moves and all of these
natural moves end up repelling black
knight h2 king h1 all of them rookie 2
or rook a2 to defend f2 they will all
come very natural to duda
the question is where is favi's play
i'm stunned uh truly and uh
wow
uh
and doris said this game is so huge huge
for our standings dude is in last place
he beats the guy who's number two
today's game is very crucial because
bobby could hurt or help himself today
so by end of the day
we'll have a better feeling about our
standing hopefully
if i
round nine dorsa totally turned
what had been an awful tournament for
three players
into something they could look forward
to in other words three players
one in round nine and all three of them
hadn't won a single game and they were
dinglerin
timor and farouja
now they get a rest day they come with
wind in their sails and they're thinking
you know like hey i just got one win can
i have a second sir you know and this
this uh playing these opponents when
they suddenly have you know good feeling
about their tournament that's not good
you you you want them down
dude
coming into today's game hasn't won a
game
if he could upset bobby that would be
amazing i didn't realize that this was
such an awkward position for fabi
doesn't make a difference alejandro
by playing
the move i don't like i i mean i stuck
my knight way out there on the rim i'm
not a happy camper but maybe for
tactical reasons
uh the the fight for tempo and other
reasons is knight a5
and this is an ugly move i don't like it
but would that help
give the tempo that
fabi needs to get his attack going it's
not about the tempe yasser no that's the
main issue with the position that it's
that you don't create as many threats as
you think you are
queen a2 or queen c2 doesn't matter
which one you choose
even if you play a move like rook f8 you
don't have an actual threat right
now knight a5 by the way the engine is
saying is much better than rook g6 okay
which is crazy
knight one h2 and then you're gonna
slowly prepare the following d4 to kill
the bishop
black can't really take
you want to fix your structure but the
pressure on c7 is annoying and you give
too many squares
and once i get d4 i'll thread in g3
because the bishop is dead the king will
come to g2 and even though there's some
pressure here we're gonna start to look
at the at the moves that ali reza
eventually ended up playing against
rajabov rook comes to e3 defends this
knight one of the rooks comes to the
second file to defend the f2 pawn and
back and back and back goes black small
updates knight a5 was just played yes
which the edges do consider to be the
top move wow wow
i just fear that this knight on a5
is going to be out of the game for i
like the move queen eight too it's gonna
be a sad horsey yeah for a long long
time but it does have potential because
in every
uh version that i think black is
fighting for an advantage it includes
the move d4
okay and at some point the move d4 when
it becomes c4 it's going to soften up
the control over this square right you
go d4 the knight is going to have access
later on to the jump c4 so i don't think
it's the worst horsey ever but it
definitely doesn't make a good
impression for now on because it's all
the way stuck on the queen side you must
think that at this point white with more
pieces on the king side should be able
to repel this attack why because this
attack is only co it's only comprised of
heavy pieces right and heavy pieces
they're worth a lot a lot less than
night the knights will just keep
attacking and keep tempoing this heavy
pieces forcing them to go back and back
and back
okay so i guess not a sad horse just a
weighty horsey
yeah it's it's in the barn waiting
barn waiting to explode we think we need
to but as we get ready for our first
break uh we want to inform
our audience about the fan the the
friends and family discounted cue
boutique normally we we offer five
percent that's usually the max
remember how i said yesterday i signed a
lease yes so i've been looking for stuff
around cube boutique and i found a few
things i like so make sure to check out
the website but uh there is a specific
chessboard that we want to bring to your
attention today
oh first of all look at the beautiful
logo on h1 yes and a8 well nice well
this is a very beautiful 22 inch wooden
chessboard that's from the world chess
hall of fame
it's a very gorgeous it has a gorgeous
wood grain on the dark squares featuring
features the world chess hall of fame
very very unique logo in the corners and
it is available only at cue boutique
nice border
right as well
so it's a wooden board but it's strange
because that almost feels like a special
yeah rice paper or something i've seen
some kind of laminates
only available at queue boutique
check it out and we are going to see you
on the other side of the break
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
you may have heard about st louis's
world-class museums art history science
even
magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun slide by
you
[Music]
those kids it is
saint lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of round 10 of the 2022
candidates these are our standings
coming in today's action yan
uh leading the competition
with a whole point over fabiano at five
and a half from start to finish so they
say hikaru and ding lynn are tied for
third uh two big games that they're
going that they're playing and let's
just get right to the games door so we
saw this move
and i gotta tell you you had a feel for
it richard rapport has played the move
king g1 to h1 a clear indication to my
mind that any kind of captures on g3 is
immediately going to be answered by f2
takes g3 no no way you put your king on
h1 and recapture with the h-pawn so that
game is still percolating and it's funny
that the move rook b1
threatening b4 was designed
as alejandro mentioned to encourage
white of playing b4 richard said nah i'm
not going to do that i'm not going to
open up the bishop uh a really big game
before we move on now king esh1 you know
it looks nice it's getting ready to take
back with the f-pawn okay but it also
feels a little uncomfortable in the
sense that i'm just you know putting my
king in front of that h8 truck right
do you how do you feel about that would
you still prefer to keep the king
i think black is doing well just full
stop right there
and i think white is going to be in a
situation where he's reacting
and so i
think the problems occurred earlier and
that richard is going to be facing an
uphill battle so yeah
but you're right i'm not happy by the
fact that
my king could
potentially be in danger at duress
knight takes g3 even if i take with the
f bomb yeah that move uh
h5 and trying to open up things on the
king side with h4 and g4 certainly
would wake me up i mean yeah it got my
attention so yeah i do think that ding
lyrin is going to be very happy with the
outcome of the opening
the opening
speaking of which
hikaru and ali reza have been playing so
slowly
it's hard to believe that
alejandro
i'm going to say 50 minutes ago said
that the
correct move
after knight d5 was rook c8 well guess
what he played it and he didn't spend
that much i mean he spent quite a lot of
time but um so is hikaru so i i it was
my understanding hikara was going to
blitz this out because he chose this
opening right exactly so now he's slow
playing it as if everything's new and
uncertain for him
and
um
after quite some time i want to say it's
very hard 140 on the clock he has
captured on f6 knight takes f6
and olly raises actually
i just realized the time sorry
he he spent how much time thinking 30
minutes
40 minutes that's what i'm saying why
you spend a lot of time deciding um
it's just
it's been very very slow now
you would think that the move queen
takes f6 recapturing the knights a kind
of automatic after all you get to
develop your queen let's get it
uh but because of what alejandro was
saying today
a lot of those players who do play those
sophisticateds vegeta double edged
positions are kind of used to these
doubled f pawns and they like the
dynamic play that results from them all
i'm saying is
queen takes f6 isn't forced like you
know the old guys myself included would
be playing queen takes f6 automatically
whereas today g7 takes f6 i think would
be an acceptable solution but alejandro
i want you to jump right in here to
explain to us why the players are
playing so slowly in this
non-theoretical position well we do have
that novelty it was a mention what you
were mentioning yasser alvarez has taken
with the pawn wow adding a new twist to
the position twice before the move queen
takes f6 had been seen with two very
nice games uh mickey adams against
victor bologna and mvl against mirosevic
so definitely high level chess at this
point they just think taking with the
queen is better i don't care what the
engines think cause gf6 is just more fun
right it puts a more
interesting twist into the game queen f6
is a drier version it's both games
actually ended in draws right so perhaps
alireza looks at the position looks at
the time situation looks at the
tournament situation right he says look
i just won a game right let me try to
win another
gtx f6 is a clear indication that he's
going in for a fight
and whether it's a good decision or not
well we're gonna let times two on that
one because it does present challenges
for black if you take on e6 taking on e6
c3 there will be some problems when the
queen comes attacking e6 you don't get
f5 in s easily because you are not
developed no you're not developed just
yet you don't want to allow knight g5
queen h5 or something similar when the
king is still so weak
so it's going to take you a little bit
of time to fix the structure you're
going to have to finish your development
first it's going to be a fun one the
king doesn't have any scores to go to i
don't think it's castling short it might
but i don't think it will and i have the
feeling that it's going to stay in the
center for quite a while
fascinating position double-edged
nothing like what we saw in their first
bout this heavy theoretical knowledge
where one side had to
key through a very racer's edge
nothing like that this is going to be
creative it's going to be dynamic both
sides full of possibilities the engine
is like white a little bit but it
doesn't really matter and remember they
only have that one draw these two
players don't have a good measure of one
another just yet i think there's a lot
that you learn the first time that you
play
a player but you get used to how they
manage their time how they put their
piece there's a lot of things you learn
about them
and this is their second bout they've
already measured themselves in the first
half let's take a look at who takes this
one hicario already down on the clock
significantly
not enough data points here uh by the
way
in the game of our tournament leader i
mean talk about
you know he could do himself a world of
good
by padding his lead
and as far as i can tell jan has done
everything right up to this moment
this bishop on d5 just came from a8 and
previously it was on d5
alejandro talked that
about this position
and the desire not
to capture with the pawn that if you do
capture with the pawn these dark squares
nicely fall under white's dominion
and you have to capture with the night
and after knight takes well
the problem is that this pawn on c4
requires urgent care
and that's why we're seeing this retreat
knight to b6
white's enjoying
from what i can tell
the advantage of the two bishops and it
really is
um
about this uh
you said it well the knight on v8 it
wants to be on on v3 you know yeah you
teleport it you know like with warp
speed
to an active square you're okay but as
long as that knight is sitting on that
ugly
uh backwards uh square on b8 you're
you're not a happy camper so this is an
advantage
yawn but uh
you know i mean there's still plenty of
work for him that
don't get me wrong it's not like
uh uh an easy game and he's going to
convert it no no it's still a lot of
work but it sure looks like a nice
advantage for him as we go again there's
yan
uh back to the game of
this one oh the beautiful bishop
yeah but i'm so mystified uh dorsa uh
really if you were to just put this
position in front of me
and say golly i really like black's
position the only thing i don't like
about black's position is this knight on
a5 and it turns out that makes all the
difference in the world just because of
what aligner was saying you're going to
play
d4
you're going to play rookie 3.
you're going to play knight h2 once you
get in all of those defensive moves then
it's going to be very easy to play g3
and drive you back yes and then you're
going to wonder what your pieces are
doing on the king side you played rook
a8 to f8 to f6 to queen to f4 and then
your pieces are going backwards and then
you've got a problem so
the question is is how does black
reinforces attack hard to do when the
knight is stuck offside so
this is actually a huge game for our
tournament standings we're going to keep
a close eye on that and then finally the
game that
whoa
well
i was going to say uh uh defies uh chess
commentary
we've seen
did you know
that rooks can move like knights i know
you didn't believe me but you see that
rook on a8
at the rook to c7
right
you open your eyes you click your heels
together
thrice
and
your rook moves like a knight
um
okay i'm alejandro
clear the cobwebs for us
what's going on what's wrong with that
truck why is it there right to begin
with
i don't know
that's why
he is considered the greatest chess
commentary
you know he is the coach of slu and sloo
chest team became the national champions
this year right this was the i think if
i'm not mistaken it was the first
national championship
in history of slu since
1948 helped me alejandra i think he was
19 47. thank you what did you guys do in
47
yeah we won
basketball basketball so it was
basketball or soccer oh soccer i think
you guys were really good at wow we have
so you're the first national champion
since 47 yes yes
we have such a big celebration it was
like nice cookies
shaped and you know the like team
team logo never mind that did you have a
ticker tape parade did the cheerleaders
all come out and
listen i'm going to complain about that
because when i became national champion
as a player at utd university of texas
of dallas my alma mater we did have a
parade when we did have cheerleaders
right i mean that's standard stuff
oh right
now you're talking about which you're
pretty good
we're going to complain about it
take it away uh and no more i don't know
either the engine likes it
the engine likes the maneuver it thinks
that rook on c7 is well placed it's much
better than on a8 that's clear that's
true but it's kind of a waiting move
it's waiting to see what richard is
going to do in some ways once this
knight disappears from c6 whether you
put it the thing is i'm not really sure
where it's going right now and you take
on before you you don't want to take us
white with the c point you always want
to take with the a pawn right in many
cases also you're wondering if you take
with the pawn i'll take with the bishop
and eventually the potential of the of
the rook
so it just wants to improve the rook
uh it does he doesn't want to play the
move bishop b7 because there will be
moments when you play bishop e6 to
counter in this bishop okay so it's a
little artificial the computer gets
completely fine
it is
actually it's very artificial to play
like this it's also challenging richie
to find a move it feels that richard has
put his pieces ready for knight takes g3
but what if i don't play it right delay
yeah what if i just keep up making
useful moves as small and minor as they
are
like rook all the way to c7
but still challenging white
to find an idea and it's still not so
easy right the move d4 is never going to
work just never c4 is going to be good
even if the pawn on d4 is not hanging
this rook i'm not sure wants to be on e1
there are many italians and real lopez
where the rook only one is very nicely
placed i don't think so here because
you've already indicated that you want
to take with the f pawn right you want
to keep that rook there
you might be able to develop this rook
somewhere i don't know something like
rook c1 okay but in many cases you
wanted to play a4
or take an a4 that lines those lines are
not so strong this knight is stuck
doesn't have a square this knight
also doesn't have a square so
it's kind of a and it's not kind it's a
very slow game it's a very slow
maneuvering game where both sides are
trying to put their pieces on their
ideal squares did i think that c7 was
the idea for the rook no but digging
around does and that's why that's how he
came up with this and what i like he's
playing quickly uh he spent half an hour
a little bit over half an hour over 17
moves i think a lot of players would
just get stuck trying to find this kind
of maneuvers he said no problem i'll
play quickly richard under an hour
already with only 17 moves played and
remember that the first few ones of
those were blitzed out
a quick question for you alejandro
where's black's king going is he going
to castle short or is he just going to
go king fa king g7 i think they're both
fine especially now that white has
indicated that you want to take with the
f-pawn
i think that you do just castle i think
it's just easier on the tempe because f5
might come at some point now remember
that i don't have to take especially
when white's taking so much time i might
play the move knight f4 okay and in in
those cases i think i'm going to be
happier with my king in the center
if he wanted to castle he could have
already done it if he wanted to play
king f8 he could have already done it
right i think at the moment he's just
biting for time and he's not going to
answer that question until the question
is actually posed to him in some way or
another and how is that question posed
by an opening whether it's an opening in
the center or the king side once the
position opens up the king's gonna more
or less need to realize where and how it
wants to go somewhere but for the now i
think it's chilling on e8
you know this sounds like a
wow
oh yes he's climbing up oh back to 2800
that's so wonderful for dink
so dingler in uh thanks to his victory
in round nine we were saying that bobby
was getting closer and closer to
leapfrogging dignity yes
bobby uh
good falling back
in these last few rounds dingler in at
20 well just above 20. that's such a 28
but what a gap between the world's
number one
and jan he's climbing up there
a near 3000 result
that he's putting together he's got a
2787 ali raza dropping
from the number three i want to say in
the world to number five
well it's very exciting for the young
alireza to have been on the world number
two for a while then it's he's still
among the best he'll he's still pretty
happy he'll come back the specific game
between rockwort and ding feels a
psychological battle rather than a chess
and it kept me you know because i i
minored a little in psychology and i was
thinking there was a specific thing
called the marshmallow test
which is
i'm all for what do i have to do
well it was a test that was done years
ago and they wanted to see how kids
would do delayed gratification so there
was a marshmallow and they would put
like different kids in front of this
marshmallow a room alone and they would
be like all right you can eat the
marshmallow now but if you wait 10
minutes and don't touch it we'll give
you like another one
so there were most of the kids just ate
it and pieced that but there were a few
kids who didn't touch it they were like
drooling a little but didn't touch it
and later in life it proved to be
actually they were
way more patient and way more thoughtful
in their daily activities so this is a
very long-term study known as the
marshmallow test this kind of made me
feel um
like this is a different marshmallow
test when am i gonna eat the g3 am i
ever gonna eat the g3
so the the the idea first of all i fail
like give me the marshmallow i don't
know i mean you know like i want it now
uh so it the delayed gratification
uh the kids got two marshmallows instead
of one but they had to wait 10 minutes
to get the second uh but later in life
that delayed gratification turned out to
be something very good in their
adulthood yeah
so that was a that was a very really
sucks that's a horrible study why do
they do these things to those points
think of the kids they never recovered
psychological damage i mean can you
imagine that alejandro i mean i thought
torture was illegal
marshmallow i think they they
they might have forgotten that or maybe
so
marsha so the idea is
don't take on g3 delay delay to delay
now having said that
let's say okay the this maneuver was
really kind of cool it was it really was
let's say i do something similar
the reason why why i i just i it's not
that this was a random choice
we've already talked about the potential
of the f-file being opened so if the
f-file
does come open there might be a reason
that this rook is actually decent
the other thing is
i do want to take i do want to resolve
and if you take with the bishop i do
especially if the file was open i do
want to like you know
throw caution to the wind and you know
have a
have a great
life right yes
but maybe maybe maybe my rook
ends up being exposed on the a1 square
so i'm i'm throwing out the move rook a2
with a purposeful idea of prepping d4
and not hanging my rook
secondly maybe the rook swings across
and it asks you the question dorsa
you're in dingler and shoes uh
how are you going to continue your game
are you going to castle
short now or
more delayed gratification get your
marshmallow later what's it going to be
girl
let's go
i mean for me i'm i'm just eyeballing
queen f6 idea because i'm thinking maybe
i can go like 97 my g6 maybe knight f4
and the other thing is like if white
really wants to play d4 then if i have
queen on f6 bringing another helper to
the d4 to as like anti-d4 to stop that
could be also nice i really do like that
rook on the c file the way i would have
thought about it i don't think i would
have ever thought about rick beatrick p7
rook c7 but i might have thought about
you know maybe i moved the bishop from
singet and gaurux c8 i thought that was
more of a
me decision but well i'm not doing their
ends right
well it's also one of those things that
in a kind of a funny way the bishop on
c8 is pretty good i mean alejandra
talked about
maybe capturing and playing a4 right so
it turns out that well maybe the bishop
defending a6 is pretty good and the fact
that the bishop is somehow patrolling
this diagonal is kind of good too
and so that was why the rook made that
kind of a strange journey now having
said all of this i have to say
that it's not that easy for white to
play i agree you got to come up with
something creative uh richie
dropped just dropped the bishop d5
on the board which well
you kind of mentioned it a moment ago
uh kind of encouraging queen f6 in 97
some sense i'm i'm a little um
i'm just trying to make my put my
thoughts together so please did richie
uh go bishop b3 the previous move to go
bishop d5 and the fact that well he
played b4
and then kicked the knight away so that
the bishop could return to b3
now maybe he wasn't thinking oh i
absolutely desperately got to jump to d5
but he got here after the move rook c7
and more or less like what alejandro was
saying he's kind of looking around
saying well what am i supposed to do for
a move am i supposed to play h3 maybe
threaten to play bishop h2 i don't know
am i supposed to put my queen on e2 am i
supposed to develop my rook rook a2 rook
c1 i don't know so he kind of played
bishop to e5 a kind of a
more of a temporizing move i want to say
maybe
he's just making room for his knight so
that he can take on c5 and play knight
b3 and d4
but again i'll come back to what you
just said if your if your intention is
white
is to break with d4 putting the queen on
f6 putting the knight on e7
somehow swinging it
uh around to the f4 square sure makes a
pleasing impression you only have to
make sure you don't blunder
and knight each five
okay and alejandro let's turn over to
you is you've got your eye on bobby's
position
fabi is looking at this game whoa
as a do or die
yeah but that last move yes it is going
for it he thinks well strategically i
must be worse and i agree
i think this part is clear that you need
to keep the pressure on the king's side
to counteract white's pressure on the
queen side and your ugly knight on a5
which is not part of the game yet right
so he's gone g5 damn subtlety out the
window
g4 is coming you might throw in the move
h5 first depending on how you want to do
things
crazy position right immediate threats
g4 is a threat if you take on a6 it's
playable according to the engine i don't
think it's playable according to humans
you go g4 ignore who cares about that
right takes takes and you have threads
rook f3 is a threat yeah i understand
that you have knight h2 but remember
there are tricks on the f2 square as
well if you throw in this move knight h2
which i think is pretty logical the
queen goes back i don't know if g7 or h5
the engines are thinking about it let's
just put it somewhere take stakes
and this allows my knight to come back
right you do get the rook in you get
rook g6 engines don't care they're not
scared plus one for white
but that's not how we play chess we look
at this position or i think black has
plenty of dynamic chances
the engines really really really hate
what uh favi's done but it's only after
a very deep thing they think the move
knight one h2 is the way to go it is a
logical move in defense and i don't have
three we've seen this idea in many
instances
and it prevents g4 pretty hard right now
the idea is that if you do go to move h5
now i have d4 and it's this important
tempo
that allows me to play d4 you don't have
time to take
g3 you're queen's track oh my god queen
is completely trapped the knight is also
defending f3 remember about that right
wow so if you play h5 you're giving me
such a crucial tempo where am i uh to
play the move d4 threaten g3 if you play
g4 you give yourself this space but you
don't help your position for example
takes takes g3 if you go to h6
i have knight takes g4 for king
game over the queen on h6 exactly game
over so knight one h2 is very important
because h5 d4 allows a humongous threat
with the move g3 which is not easy to uh
to answer you have to move the rook
somewhere probably g6 or h6 because you
have to keep an eye
on the e6 pawn right you can't go rook
f8 so you have to go something along the
lines of this g3 queen f6
but
again engines aren't impressed with this
they play the move rook f1 rook d1 is
completely fine by the way
but they start consolidating they just
put the rook on f1 and they say yes yes
nice pawn pushes eventually i'll be
better because of the weaknesses that
you're leaving behind the pawns
engines cold-blooded we don't care what
they think this is going to be a fun
game
something's going to happen
and we're going to see how favi tries to
exploit duda's position here on the king
side it's going to be a wild one it's a
risky one bobby thinks it's do or die
nothing in between let's go g5 i'm not
entirely sure just yet what he's
planning to do against knight one h2 i
suspect it's not h5 because d4 just
looks so strong
right but if it's not h5
what is it i haven't gotten to that
conclusion just yet it might be rook g6
to begin with but and just like white
i don't care let's go yeah it's a fight
it's not easy to play for either side
well one of the things to to my mind
dorsa and alejandro
when i think about generations of
players and the players of today
improving
quantitatively
more than the previous generations it's
that their defensive play has gone
through the roof i mean in the old days
you know we would collapse in the face
of a single threat
now these guys using their engines are
used to
finding
uh resources in the position that
my generation met we just look at
position go oh dear you know we see g5
we go ah you know like black's got a
very serious initiative the engines are
as alejandra are saying cold-bloodedly
saying that
nothing
still feels like such a nice
wish-blocking move you literally play g5
you want to go g4 i'm just gonna wish
block i'm just gonna play night touch
too and i'm just gonna sit there and
smile and maybe wiggle my eyebrows a
little so
i'm what do you call it wish block
what's that where does that come from
black is wishing to play pawn to g4 i'm
just gonna block it a wish block okay
you see
you never know what you're gonna learn
on the chess channel like wish block
okay i'm gonna block your wishes yeah do
you have a
wishbone like the chicken as a whisper
it's actually a very nice cultural thing
in iran too because like there's always
like you would um
not fight away with like two people
right yeah
the longer one is the lucky one i always
won and i never got my wish i can't
remember what my wishes were
it was terrible i did
wish
block yes wish block okay so knight h2
this wish block
i'm going to say that three times fast
d4
and that's a cold-blooded shower
that g3 is actually trapping your queen
and uh after moves like this g3 i kind
of think that that's a funny move that
rook f1
i was thinking we would play king g2 or
something but
this does look like an attack gone
wrong like that i'm not really
yeah i'm not really happy with fabi's
position here after the move g5
and the wish block knight h2
and how are we doing in our other games
i just want to once again drop in on
ikaru oh that's going to be a slow game
slow game slogan bishop d3 only played
11 they just play uh
just played
i know
and they both spent nearly an hour each
you could argue these are the number two
and number three best bullet players in
the world
and they are the slowest this is not
classical players
whatever
i mean alireza plays this like hundred
game matches against magnus and it's
it's dazzling to see the speed that he
comes up with ideas the speed that he
sees tactics the even the physical speed
with the mouse
to even make moves but somehow he gets
into classical chess and he just gets
stuck
that also makes me think because we saw
their head to head and they've only
played once in classical so how much
does that actually like what in your
opinion how much does that one classic
game matter since they've been playing
forever online versus each other
not too darn much i mean no seriously uh
it's just not enough data points right
and uh we've seen some of these players
who have played 33 draws eight
losses seven wins and they're so close
they know each other inside and out but
you're absolutely right uh alejandro 100
game bullet match
you kind of get a pretty good feel of
your opponent after 100 games of bullet
i don't even care
you know what the score is you get a
good idea you get a good sense of what
your opponent likes and dislikes
yeah absolutely but it's
i just jump right in
it's not classical chess no so
but are you saying it properly it's only
one one game that they've played against
each other i mean i think hikaru knows
how fabi plays chess they've played a
few times against each other just a few
a couple
i think it's over 50.
they they know how they react to
different problems
right and this one is a completely new
battlefield for them between hikaru and
alireza they don't know each other as
well
what they do know
is that draws
doesn't help either of their
campaigns draws are no good when they
played the first time around a draw was
okay the tournament was still kind of
wide open yeah nepo had won a game and
hikar had lost one but however recovered
by that point he had already been in
timor so he was back to 50 percent
in this one they look at the situation
of the tournament they say
man
how do i become world champion right
and at this point it's not by passing
nepo
maybe it's passing favi
right
why not that's the only chance you as
chess players we do this
we give ourselves something to aspire to
and in this case if second place
is perhaps an outside chance that you
get a world championship match you start
thinking i need i need points i need
full points right and i think it's nice
to see both of these players going for
it
what would be nicer is if they actually
stepped on the gas pedal
made some moves because i don't want
this going down to a furious
few minutes
position in which anything can happen
right and then we see a bunch of
blunders i want these guys to bring
their best chess
against each other it's the candidates
one hour exactly for hikaru to make 29
moves
yeah that's right and alireza
has an hour and seven
it's not quite time pressure but you
start thinking about it yeah especially
no increments
but they must have spent those two hours
in the last three moves because you know
the first half dozen moves they played
rather
quickly instantly
after a thing of uh not that long
actually 97 was played preparing the
hinting at d5 hinting at f5 i like this
move it's a typical svashnikov type move
yeah everything to play for in this
position guys brand new but as you
mentioned hikaru was the one that
proposed this variation
fabi um not favi alireza thought for a
while played the move knight c6 and this
is how he replied
but it doesn't seem like either one is
fully familiar with the structure they
seem to think it's very complex and
they're going to spend their time trying
to decide how many different
possibilities that are in this position
are you going to go d5 you're going to
go f5 you're going to develop the bishop
do you throw in rook g8 do you not throw
in rook j do you castle long do you
castle short do you castle at all does
this not go to h4 first or do you first
make the king safe there are so many
questions here that are difficult to
answer that this is why they're thinking
a lot
does that excuse the amount of time
not so sure about that one but it's not
a position where
it's a clear-cut plan and you can just
find moves easily every move has little
subtle details that need to be compared
against one another
dorsa do you have an approach that you
would take if you were in ikaru shoes
do would you be
castling and putting your king into
safety before undertaking anything
active or would you say let's hit while
the iron's hot this is a very weird
situation for me because as a sister i
play
sicilian as uh well i place design
little as black but i encounter a lot of
it as white okay and for me i i really
like that king safety i really like
playing against that d5 square so even
in swedishness that's a little tricky c4
line instead of c3 has been you know
right paying off well for me okay i love
that my deforestation will guard your
secrets you want to let everybody know
what it's about yeah so i'm just trying
to decide like how can whites
do which do stuff on the d5 scroll how
can my wish for the d5 square
uh come true because black is preparing
to push pawn to d5 and right either as
alejandra said either it's
the knight e7 is supporting both breaks
f57 is a very sneaky and i think i want
to say cool move yeah i'm in one if i'm
in white shoes i'm kind of like i would
love as white to get in two
moves in a snap if i could go knight h4
and queen h5
life's good would you want a long cast
till then
no i'm putting my king safely on the
king's side i feel that
whatever attack that you if i go knight
h4 and you go rook g8 i really feel that
this attack this attack is no attack at
all and that you well first of all you
might even want to
you know double
check that you want to play this
variation check might be awkward so i'm
not even sure rook g8 is a good move but
i'm thinking that
my king has lots of guards a good pawn
shield and will be safe on the king side
and if you play the move d5 what the
move knight e7 was all about supporting
d5 well i'll jump out here
and
please
blunder into my ea
i mean exactly so i'm thinking knight h4
but i could also
hey
you know get behind castles what you
want you know okay
i love a safe king you sign me up so
that's my my goal in chess i mean forget
you know like
hundreds and thousands of books have
been published on the openings right
what's my goal i want my fair share
of the center my you know i want to
control the center i want good
development for my pieces and i want to
save king those are my three goals so in
this position if you put castles on the
board i say well my pieces are effective
right
this is good this is good this is good
well i'd like to improve this i'd like
to improve this but one step at a time
i've got pretty decent control of the
center i got to save king so i'm
figuring white's done his job
and then i look across the board and i
say
oh
black has a long way to go he's still
got to catch up
his king's not at this moment safe his
development well is not spectacular this
bishop isn't on g7 you haven't castled
and you haven't made a break so i'm
thinking it's easier to play white does
that necessarily translate into a big
advantage i don't know but i think
knight h4 and castles are the two moves
i like
um very very comfortable candidate moves
the only thing i'm trying to decide on
is do i want to be nice to opponent and
let their wishes of potential d5 and f5
come true or do i want to
stop them stop before approaching
exactly
so and that's the move castles one of
the other things though that's going on
in the position
is normally speaking
you
don't want to open up the position
when you're behind the development so if
i play move like castles and you play d5
and just i'm going to just put it on the
board takes takes normally speaking
you're doing me the biggest solid
because
i i i'm supposed to have the better
development i'm supposed to be liking
the fact that you're opening up the
position in my favor so those are some
of the things that iqara was thinking
about and again such a huge game for
caru coming off a loss in round nine and
now i
there was a
topic i'm very sore i'm very upset about
it
that i want to come back to i want your
opinion as well as alejandro's on this
i'm very angry yeah very angry about
this
free day yesterday ah okay free day
yesterday so all of the players
deep breaths
preparing themselves for what's going to
be
crucial
rounds to come
hikaru
streams for
goes on plays title tuesday because very
nice tournaments that they have every
weekend
week on chess.com i don't care earns
thousands of dollars so in the middle of
the most important tournament of his
life
how does he spend his free day
working as a streamer your take was that
as if you were his coach would you be
hopping mad
or would you say oh that's icarly see
that's the thing i feel like people have
different coping mechanisms and they
have different strategies strategies on
how do they spend their free time i feel
like the way hikaru did it
might not look the most healthy one but
he i feel like if he enjoys doing it
sometimes i enjoy just binge watching
somebody enjoys going to gym for like
three hours or swimming or
everybody does something different so i
feel like if that's something that suits
hikaru and gives him a better feel for
the next day who am i to tell him not to
do it okay good good good good i need
that kind of feedback so i'm not hopping
mad alejandro your take uh if i can ask
the producers
for the percentage chances of winning
this tournament
i think we have this graphic
up
with us give me a second i just want to
analyze something it was like one
percent that's what you're getting it's
less that's where he's going maybe
dingleran had 1.1 percent i feel like i
can read alejandro yes all right after
round eight after okay after around nine
hicary has point nine percentage
title tuesday sounds great
[Laughter]
enjoy his tuesday
if he wanted to unwind by playing chess
i let him unwind by playing chess
this this wasn't hikaru's tournament it
wasn't even that he played badly
but some of the positions that he got it
was a bit unlucky he got out prepped a
couple of times
and he just wasn't able to fully show
who he is i felt he was stifled a little
bit and of course the disaster against
for a job of happens already in a
situation in the tournament where things
are not going his way where somebody's
running away with it
if he's going to stream and do his
actual job on on this tuesday and play
some chess and show that he can play
it's even good for him to unwind a
little bit everybody's got their style
let him be
you guys are way way too nice wait a
minute i want to invite our audience to
join the conversation
and come to us through social media
because i'm hopping mad if i'm
i'm the dude's second and i'm putting
uh my my blood sweat and tears into
hikaru's success and i want him to have
a success and you're saying to me ah let
the guy chill let the guy play his blitz
i need some support guys i mean come on
audience you know you know like you know
lift me up put these guys down
yes sir
speaking of wishing and you know fun
games and tournament leaders it makes me
want to look at our tournament leaders
game okay let's do it yeah
yeah yes because uh from what i remember
um we left it around yeah and it was
mentioned that that night on v8 finally
fine
what move was it uh go a little bit
farther for me one more
four yes finally that one
he remembered
he's got another piece on the queen side
but it does feel like black is kind of
wish-blocking white now and there might
be uh more equality than the last time
we were looking at this game okay so we
do have the inclusion of the move bishop
to d4
queen to d6 on the board and let's take
a look so
oh boy uh
well can we start with some captures
right that is what happened in the game
yes it did it already okay knight takes
d7 so what happened next well somebody
got to eat somebody
wishful thinking there's a lot of stuff
happening the d4 is a little wobbly d7
is wobbly i'm assuming we're capturing
on f6 if i capture it on d7 i was a
little bit worried about a back rank
mate right i completely agree with that
oops that could be an issue what do you
think about queen takes d4
i'm not sure just a second queen takes
d4
okay is
is there a problem with queen b7 i'm not
sure just
i'm putting it on the board for a moment
that's a check
now
there is this
oh well queen b2 wait a minute could be
completely wrong about this queen b2
rook d1
okay
queen takes d4
because i feel like black is the one
under more pressure so if i can
get rid of some of that pressure by
changing
i would be happy
okay just to just to look if i take
take now the problem is i'm not
even sure if i'm going to win this pawn
by playing knight takes bishop takes
e3
dreaming of bishop f1 you might have
bishop a5 just looking at e3
could i take that pawn i mean it's
there's two
wishing but do no wishing is good that's
the problem i think you can in fact
take the pawn you hit the rook
and you're just fine so there's no
problem so that looks like it's
equalizing uh dorsa i think that
that
timor
played accurately and solved his
problems
and
let's uh just take a a look at the line
score of ion
that's just that's just picture perfect
i mean look at that unblemished the only
player in the whole field
to go undefeated but that plus four
exactly he's just seven
but timor on the other hand
if it wasn't for that round nine he'd be
really really crying and what an upset
it was as team usa he beat kukaru in
that round
uh minus two
uh not bothering anybody and according
to alejandro it was like three years ago
that he had a
victory
that is to say teamwork classical he
plays in these top top top events where
you know he could draw a lot of games
but he finally won
so it was a good tournament for him
after all
well the remarkable thing is that that
one victory you know just makes up for a
lot of uh unpleasantness yes and it
looks like um
a draw is in store in that game again
we're going to just check in on fabi
guess what the they're going right down
that
that pathway that um
alejandro said after g5 knight h2
uh putting a
a pause on the move g4
rook g8 fabby recognizing that after
this move d4
g3 was an issue so he wanted to sidestep
that
h5 and g3 was just actually played and
they're
transposing
into the position that you prescribed
alejandro which was takes
takes and rook f1
how
big an edge is it for white two
ah
two pawns two whole puns that's what it
says it's plus two in this position well
i guess that's do or die
well that means somebody's dying i got
bad news for
team usa yeah by the way i'm a very
objective neutral
here not
i mean i thought this as a saint louis
chess club we're more uh
fanboys exactly that's exactly what we
are we're fanboys
we're guilty guilty as charged okay
sorry alejandro please take it away yeah
that's what the engines think of course
for me as a human i just think it's a
position where perhaps black is worse
because of the structure but i don't
know how much worse
uh it just hates black's position you
don't even have to take on e5 you can uh
you can also just start with the mover
okay d1 right which makes a lot of sense
to me you don't solve the tension in the
center right now what is the issue for
black
where do you make progress right you
want to play g4 you want to play h4 but
neither one of those moves is good right
if you play this and for example let's
just put a bad move on the board you go
like this and i take take the moment i
defend this knight
i get knight g4 in king g2 you go king
g2 and you start threatening knight g4
and at some point let's say that you
keep attacking i'll keep defending
queen e2 rook d3 all of these moves easy
to find right the moment you hold the
knight you're going knight g4 nice tempo
everything collapses for black also
those double eyes lyte palms are just
not not doing anything except just you
know sitting there targets yeah yep
they're targets so after the move g3
queen f6 if i go again rkd1 and you go
the other break let's go g4 okay
the problem is that i take take and
you're just anchoring my knight
nice knight on h4n this is a weakness on
g4 right again because your pieces are
here
you can't hold on to it at some point
i'll go king g2 queen e2 or kg2 even f3
and then i'll remind you that your
pieces are here and my pieces are here
the kings are here
so if too much gets traded the knights
are going to start attacking the king
i'm going to start to have avenues it's
not going to be played on one goal
anymore that sounds ominous so after
queen f6 if i just play the movie rook
d1 black's challenge is to get everybody
involved i am white i'm killing your
bishop the knight is already dead so i
don't have to worry about that you want
want to play a move like rook f8 and i
think this is the most logical way of
playing you put the rook on f8 you start
targeting things down the file i expect
then i move like rook d3 i'm sure there
are other moves in the position
so what duda's trying to figure out
right now just do you want to take on e5
first or do you want to develop the rook
first maybe he wants to hold on to the
knight by playing king g2 he has options
the game is far from over it's just that
the engines don't like where they see
this game headed
yeah i don't like it either i really
don't i mean i like everything that
you're saying white's play is very easy
rook to d1
rook to d3 king to g2
and any time you play g4 i'll go knight
h4 practically anytime you play h4 when
my knight on f3 is protected i'll go
knight g4 and what you were saying about
those double isolated polymers in the
center they're targets i don't want to
question how
how
human f1 is
but the thing is like i also remember
this is years ago i was still you know
up and coming in i i remember i was like
uh trying to understand more how to play
roy lopez as white and i saw a lot of
classical games with just bringing the
rook back to f1 getting ready for pawn
f4 so if i can remember that i have a
feeling dude i can't too exactly well in
this case whether it's rook f1 to defend
f2 or rook d1
to defend d4 and then onwards to defend
f3 rook t3 essentially the bottom line
is that the moment white absolutely
positively shuts down the king's attack
so that there's no
possibility of black ever breaking
through
you've got to turn and face the music
that the knight on a5 and the bishop on
a7 on the queen side are out of play
and that
black
white has more pieces on the king's side
than black does by the way i want to get
in this uh very exciting news that we
are going to have a very special guest
yes maxine bashar lagrave or as viktor
korchnoy famously said the frenchman
with three names what's his name what's
his name a frenchman with three names is
going to be joining us uh i think on the
other side of the break i believe so yes
so we will take a quick break and we'll
be back right with you everybody
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profits
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the u.s
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the us and world chess halls
of fame
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stl
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
after nine rounds of play we have these
standings with yon of course leading by
one point
all the games of round 10 are still
underway no results and a lot of results
are still possible all three results i
feel are possible in a number of games
however it does feel to me
like our tournament leader
is about to make a draw yeah most likely
we are seeing the game between and jan
uh nepo and
timor and after there was a number you
know it took forever for the night on b8
to come out but once it came out
black solved all of his problems knight
b8 to d7 trades trades and look looky
looky it's a bishops of opposite color
four versus four absolutely nothing to
play for well like what background
checkmate is always possible true
yeah he just protected uh
that one though uh with the move queen
a6 funnily enough on our break we're
actually looking at the move queen d8
and we had worked out an absolutely in
my opinion brilliant way
of making a professional three-time
repetition
by putting the queen the bishops
actually
on the furthermost square
uh here how do you feel about pawn g6 to
get the bishops quite symmetrical yeah i
i i like that i mean if we had put our
pawn on g6 i i i'm warming up to what
you're saying and then we get to go
bishop i was just enamored by this uh
the length of the bishops anyway we
thought that was a professional way of
making a draw the players actually have
played the move queen a6 and this one
oh we could specie and queen a8
i mean exciting moment
in this game for for yan
close enough close enough well it does
actually check this out very symmetrical
please please please the geometry is
just spectacular after the move g7 g6 we
would say
black has equalized
because you see
black
so they will they will figure out a
three two three move repetition before
too long again draw a you see
a8 now very very
this is so pretty oh sir you called us
way ahead of time and i just came up
with the g6 too and the production team
is going to
reach deep into their pockets and pull
out that green and say yes
[Laughter]
this is ideal for for for nepo
uh as he cements his point lead and why
because look at what's going on in the
game between duda
who hasn't won a single game just a
second well uh yeah crystal i believe
the draw
is
it's going to be secure very very very
sure
um
alejandro we on our break
we were both
official officially draw we were both
very deeply concerned
that fabi's position
it is it's very dangerous
he he could be in serious trouble the
more you engine things the more
the worse it gets for favi right let's
just put it that way duda is playing a
very
straightforward plan with the move king
h1 we mentioned before the idea of king
g2 to hold on to the king side yeah but
because of this move rook g7 instead of
the immediate rook f8
duda i think
sees a chance
to stick a knight on g5 h4 knight g he's
gonna go h4 let's make uh some passing
move right rook b8 i'm just passing to
make a point right if you go h4 and you
go g4 well uh thank you for that square
yeah and e6 pawn too the e6 pawn is
vulnerable and you're just waiting for
me to go rook f1 f3 and open you on the
king side right this is dead lost
if you take on h4
i have options but i think i would jake
with the g pawn
wow if you take if you stick a knight on
f4
i'm concerned i'm crying yes but you're
not i'm just going to get drunk you want
in
on a5 he's not going to f4
there's not going there the queen can't
go there i don't care but the queen is
very lonely right it needs to keep
defending the pawn on e6 first of all
right and also the g file
totally busted totally busted right
white just has more pieces on the king
side and the king side is where the
action is end of story
uh if you
allow h4 in this move you're basically
lost but what do you do against it it's
not it's not really clear what you can
do against it at all the the move g4
knight h4 also doesn't help you
if you go something like rook cafe let's
say it's more relevant it doesn't really
change anything i'm still gonna go h4
you're gonna take and now i can take
with the knight in this case queen takes
f2 is a possibility because you've added
the rook but you have to watch out for
queen takes e6
but what's changed in pawn takes
absolutely nothing yeah you can double
the rooks and it's not as dangerous as
it was in the previous one
but nothing's preventing me from going
rook g1 using g5 as a springboard
for either a knight or a rook and then
either bringing the other rook behind
the rook that will be on g5 or using the
move knight g5 to attack the pawn on e6
not to mention that there will be ideas
of queen e2 queen h5 you know what the
more the engine thinks about this the
more lost it is and the more i think
about it
the more lost it is
kh1 is a great move i think eg2 was also
giving an advantage to what king h1 is
more direct it's saying your pieces are
on the wrong side of the board they're
all on the a file right i'm gonna go
h4 h4 use the fact that you came and get
me
to just bounce back the attack on your
own king
and i don't i don't see how you get out
of this for black at all
it
it's crazy and so infuriating
again in round nine we we return to this
fateful round where three players
all won and they hadn't won a single
game and the games they won were
terrific yes i mean timor
what can you do he won a model game he
played like a beast against cicara
really and duda right now i mean the guy
hasn't won a single game and he's
playing
like he's boss man
oh you're in the tournament he's the
only one left he's the only candidate
that hasn't won a game of chess in this
tournament right well
and fabi is sitting there saying
why do i get to why do i have to play
this guy i want to play the guy who's
been playing terribly for the last uh
nine rounds this is this is impressive
stuff by duda yeah duda is bringing it
he's a very dangerous player and he is
exhibiting
why he is a candidate he's been so shut
down through the tournament he's not
been able to give us any of his ideas
he's played horribly in a couple of
games the game he goes against lost
against rapport was slightly
embarrassing horrifying you you put your
opponent's pawn on g5 and then you get
mated down the h file
for no counter play right that was a
terrible game right but duda
is such a great player right he's such a
great attacker he finds so many
resources there's a reason that this
young polish superstar qualified he won
the world cup he beat magnus on his way
he
broke magnus hundred and some
non-losing streak right i mean young
dude shishtaf has been talk of the town
forever
he is such a strong player so talented
and he's finally showing up think of her
favi is like dude
we had all tournament to do this one
today
right that's what's so infuriating and
unfair about the whole thing i mean you
you you kind of came into this game at
least from fabi's point of view fabi's
coming into the game
okay coach uh who do i play today you
play the guy in last place yes
that sounds promising i should go all
out for the win right yes
and look what he's like king h1 with
this idea of h4 and again
the what
alejandro is saying i remember
bill grandmaster bill lombardi who was
the second of uh bobby fischer we had
played together a number of tournaments
but it was specifically in lone pine
california this wonderful event that
took place there annually
and i was just analyzing some position
where it was an attack
and
bill comes and says he was a priest
right yes sir yes sir stop stop what
you're doing count the pieces
so it's like one two
count the pieces that are attacking so
on the king's side if white plays as
alejandro prescribed h4 gh you've got to
overcome your prejudice and recapture
with the pawn so again we're going to
just put some moves on the board
but this move is fascinating you open
the g file
purposely that was why
we saw do to play the move king h1 and
then you play rook g1 and you count the
pieces the attackers
on the king side versus what your pieces
are doing on the queen side and and bill
lombardi would say
h4 gh exclamation mark
white's winning
and he would be right uh this is exactly
what uh
what fabi is facing and it's no
coincidence that he's spending some time
now having said all of this what are the
clock times he's not going to be able to
i believe
that
yes uh duda has 53 minutes
fabi has 33.
and it's not an easy position by the way
we do have it officially now
uh
with this draw
um
jan is going to move up to a seven
points and said that
nine was our magic figure
nine when we started the broadcast on
day one
this magic fair keeps going up oh we
started our broadcast thinking it was
eight and a half
but nepal was doing so well we bumped it
up to nine to nine and then we might be
bumping down to nine and a half we've
got four games well we i mean remaining
for nepta unfortunately for saint louis
said louisiana said louise
uh if bobby does not stumble yes if he
doesn't get a point today he'll he will
stay at five and a half and i do think
that that does change the magic number
for nepo yeah it goes down
you might be looking at eight winning
the tournament clear first right but
a a fabby loss and if we could just put
that current standings back for just a
moment again timor has already made a
draw that's why he's got four and a half
but it would open the door
for ding lauren
and hikaru who are currently on four and
a half dingler and with a win fabi loses
with a win ding loren jumps to a tie for
second with a win hikaru jumps for a tie
for the second and we're thinking
because
magnus is basically intimated he may not
play the world championship so this
might not be a win or take all situation
playing for second place
suddenly could be a very very big deal
and that's why
this game that duda is playing i mean
dude is playing a great game against
fabby and fabi saying
why go for the marshmallow
eat the marshmallow get out of here we
just have by the way rook f8 on the
board
uh and the idea i think is that
it is a time
no e6 is hanging
if you take on f2
oh my gosh queen takes e6 and the
floodgates uh open on the king side to
whites in favor so
how does rook f8
stymie h4
oh don't ask me ask somebody stronger
than me exactly well we have it with us
a special guest we have a special
frenchman and a former candidate maxine
vasherlagraf welcome to the show i'm
sure that you've been watching this with
baited breath tell us your opinions
how's it going
hey alejandro hey yes sir hey
good to see you hello hello hi
it's been a long time also
we will be
in saint louis for united in august so
wonderful excellent we have the bug
house table waiting for you
really can't wait right uh your first
impressions about the candidates
um
well
one thing was not surprised for me is
that nepal was
playing good
like i thought he would perform well i
thought it would be one of the
contenders
uh i thought there would be four main
contenders for the victory so it would
it was
young
it was fabi it was sting and it was
already
um that was my thought before the
tournament obviously some of the things
uh have not been going as uh i predicted
but uh
as the two horses that are still you
know in the ways are among these four
uh
talk about ali raza's performance uh
you're you're
you're a frenchman
exactly right
um yeah i must say um it's been a
difficult tournament for him although he
must have been relieved that he was out
to
to win yesterday finally he's been
trying very hard
and there's been a few things that have
not been working for him uh sometimes
his preparation has been working but
lately it hasn't been so great
in the last few games
and also his time management
has always been an issue i think
with him sometimes he was playing too
fast
lately he was playing too slow and this
time again i think he's tanking in on
some decisions where
he shouldn't release so
you know but
we can still see you know the potential
why
why is such a rising star where he
helped us to
uh to win the silver medal in european
team championship where he won the
countries so you know there's
definitely up for for the future for for
friends
with
and i yeah well it's quite interesting
so i knew ali rizzo when he was yay high
he's the same age as my brother so they
would play in the same u championships
and i would prepare against him and it
was very fun
i know he has a very very supportive
father and i do think that's one of his
huge success reasons is his family
support
on top of his own talent
but the other question i have two
questions for you question number one
uh is about the painting i'm sorry is
that a chess board in the middle of that
yeah okay nice it's it's not my painting
i'm not at my
we will place ask where
i'm at a friend's place no nice that's
what it's a very capturing um
i was gonna compliment you on your good
taste as well get out of here you're
faking it it's fake news
news yeah you you don't want to see my
apartment
i thought it was a french impressionist
painting with some chessboards
i thought i thought it was maybe a
goldfish wretched oh no that's a that's
a chess board in the middle that's very
wonderful okay that takes care of
question number one non-arts uh question
well what are your thoughts on the the
potential
the
idea that magnus will not play nepo if
he wins how do you where do you think
that's gonna go
well i think first that magnus is
generally brutally honest when he says
something
at least parts of him thinks that it's
true and so there's a very serious
chance
that he will not play if nepo or maybe
someone else wins
and i can understand that because of
course working uh
six months in advance for every
championship match
can be growing and it's been 10 years
for for magnus so
you know i i wouldn't i wouldn't be
surprised if he sticks to his opinion i
also wouldn't be surprised if he decides
to actually play like he said
it's a matter that's begging him and
that he's
thinking about himself
now the question is of course uh whether
he
if he actually wants
another type of cycle
for the world championship maybe not any
match
then he probably should offer
a replacement if if you really think
that's the way to go
i mean
there's an argument for that so it's uh
but it's definitely i mean the body
needs is in his cart
wonderful um
if i can turn your attention uh maxine
to
a position that you may be familiar with
the nydorf uh
ikaru versus yeah ali raza you get that
has been playing it in the opening
was not made of like it was most
efficient of like actually right right
um your take on the current opinion
position we've seen a trade on b3
d5 takes queen takes
and we are up to date with the players
after the move c2 c4
how would you break down the position
for our audience and
who stands better
i will say two things so
one thing
is that i think this position should be
better for white in general even though
there's uh chances
of course for ali reza because it's such
a dynamic position
king is still in the center but it's not
yet a big issue could become one in the
next two months but let's say there's
still time to castle
and second thing well i've been played
ikea with few times
i think this is the kind of position
that you
kind of want to avoid against him
and
uh this is why i'm surprised that
arizona went straight into
a
position where i'm gonna you on that one
when you say this type of position is
what you want to avoid with the car what
what factors of the position is it that
you think hikaru does very well
yeah it's just very open position lots
of things to calculate lots of potential
for initiative for ikaru like he's not
gonna be stuck in defense
and that's why i'm surprised because uh
if we
see the opening from the start which i
will play knight f3
after e5 uh lots of options
are just uh you know like the main line
is bishop e7 bishop c4
uh
castle and then bishop e6 it's just a
quite slow quite long game i mean i'm
not saying that ikaw is a bad player in
there for sure not but i think he's a
better player in the position we we
currently are have on the board
and uh yeah it just feels like this idea
could be
interesting uh but
like personally if i had been using this
idea it would have been against another
player
i see from
hikaru's point of view he's just played
the move c4
and it looks to me like that's a
preparatory move
to play d5 and
seize the open default maybe maybe rook
a5 and rook d5 same idea i kind of like
white's position uh
maxine yeah that's basically what i'm
saying so c4 is still a very responsible
move because uh in end games you
definitely don't want this sort of fan
games with opponent b3 being kind of
stuck now right um
and we can see that ali reza played
bishop g7 it's gonna castle uh we can
see his time management again like i've
not been following the wall game but
it's been like
20 move stops yeah yeah and he has 27
minutes left so
yeah not even no not even 20. he doesn't
move 17.
okay yeah
so ikawi doesn't have that much time
left so that means that it was a
difficult position to navigate i mean
like there's a reason that you're done
on 27 minutes after so so few moves but
still
it strikes me as an issue in because you
know um things are definitely not
further from here like it's not uh it's
not gonna be uh
you know
it's a cruise
no no not at all
uh by the way uh as i'm looking at the
position i'm i'm attracted to the move
rook d5
but you know maxine what i would love i
would love to see the move knight f5
takes e3
yes
yeah and then that then the white knight
taking over possession of the so like if
i could play queen in
this
i got a dream position right i don't
really like queen c2 because after queen
e6 i don't know what we've achieved
which was queen e4
you see i
on the panel uh i have a reputation
26 was
reaction 26 was bad okay so actually
actually queen c2 is interesting i was
thinking even about something more
direct knows that ali played bishop g7
yes
he closed his options for rook g8 so g4
struck me as an option right trying to
force to do the same thing basically wow
okay that's
that's lifting your kimono though
you're
exposing yourself uh mvl
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah this is the dream
that you could establish a night there
wonderful um you mentioned that you're
coming definitely it's a safer option
like i like it actually right you
mentioned that you're coming uh to
st louis uh we're going to provide you
of course as a wonderful st louis
welcome you got the grand chess tour uh
now that uh the uh the grand chess tour
is also a part of the feed a cycle right
there's you you you get two qualifiers
what are your thoughts about your own
candidacy
for a future candidates you want to get
back in the mix
well certainly and
you know i
do think i will have a good chance to
qualify through so manchester but uh
you know
in any case i would have been ready to
to fight for for a spot among the
candidates because ultimately it's my
goal to play the candidates and to win
them and then
even ultimately to to win the match so
you know it's
uh i haven't qualified so often i've
been very often extremely close and uh
you know i still haven't given up
i do have another question for you as
well because
i was looking on
the rating the live ratings and i
noticed that
well there's so many players that are so
wonderful and they've they're very
qualified and they're definitely super
grandmasters in your opinion what does
it take to cross 2800 and stay on that
level
well
lately it's been basically only magnus
we should be asking magnus
yeah is this your suggestion
i think so uh
but of course um
i mean
like a lot of players have been you know
in the past few years
managing to together and to stay there
for at least a few months
like for me or a few years like fabi
like 11 at some point
[Music]
and maybe think also i think like the
two most consistent players apart from
magnus in the last 10 years were were
fabian levant so you know
um
i just think it's about
you know
it just means that every player who
managed to cross 28 android like shah
like myself like a cow at some point who
had very high eyes and like
basically we are playing uh definitely
at the level of magnus for a few months
but we didn't manage to to keep it that
way so
i think it's a sort of stability that
magnus pushes to the extreme
and that's kind of lacking maybe
for some of us like we have stability
definitely over 2750
uh quite close to 2800 but staying
over 2800 is uh a real awesome
yeah the consistency factor is is really
really really remarkable there
one more because we have you here and i
want you analyzing stuff we're going to
have to work
yeah
between
richie and dingler and it's been crazy
oh i mean it's black to move so yeah
so yeah
um
yeah
i don't know so like what i see
immediately white's king is not safe i
mean it's safe for now but if the
dark puppy shop
is not there to coverage for it's
definitely not safe because the king is
stuck
uh
well black skin cannot be called as safe
for obvious reasons
so
it's pretty much a mess position that
the computer would uh
evaluate uh
much better than i do but
uh
i mean
if i were to choose i probably stick
still pick white
uh but objectively i think black must be
at least fine maybe more than that
um
yeah i must say that doing has been
playing better in the past few
few days and uh well it's satisfying
because you had a
pretty tough start
of the event
um
on on the um
personage of a ding laran
um he's a great player full stop end of
story yes he works incredibly hard to
get to the candidates
and when he gets the candidates it's
almost like everything goes wrong why
why well it's amazing
okay so the first candidates
no
actually the first candidate that he
played he was remarkably consistent i
think he won one game made 13 draws
so he was still gathering experience but
very solid performance i would say
second candidates he played was in
under very special circumstances let's
say he was uh
out in quentin for like two weeks maybe
more
before after i mean i i can understand
that you know not every player will
react uh well to that and he definitely
didn't so
this time
i think it's on him uh basically
like i'm just very surprised he hasn't
played
much uh over the ball chess in the past
few months i mean that one is not on him
and at least he could play over the
board in in china in
i think in
in april right so that was more or less
okay
but how do you get to the place only
three days before
and the like that's that's jet flag
i don't know but i didn't know about
iran but that's uh something uh
not great either but
like there's jet flags there's we
just getting back with the touch of
top-level chess you know he hasn't seen
uh all of those guys for for one year no
so
you know i think he definitely
would have wanted to be there like a
week before like
uh one hour per hour one day per hour of
jet lag like that's the bare minimum
time zone difference absolutely
nbl thank you so much for joining us
it's always a pleasure to see you we
look forward to your eventual arrival in
st louis exactly and uh
you look very well you look healthy you
look how happy nice to see you yeah i
don't have the tension of playing as a
that must be candidate
that's it
yeah thank you thank you very much thank
you maxime all right bye
and
alejandro i gotta turn this over to you
uh because i'm looking at this game of
duda
and fabi and it seems to me that white's
achieved exactly what you have been
prescribing for him it looks great for
white
yeah it's more than great uh the engines
thought about it for a while i wouldn't
have ever guessed this evaluation but
it's 4.3 i just saw that number whoa
that's a monster number 4.3 means you're
up more than a piece that's monster it's
all the same that we've talked about the
rooks coming to g1 how do you deal with
rook takes g7 if you move this rook to
f7 how do you deal with you're stuck to
these two pawns by the way this queen
coming to e6 would just finish the game
right the knight doesn't have a way back
you might as well try to get the bishop
back but it's only on a defensive
purpose
and because of the knights
you just don't have threats
you don't create any threats against
white ever
not in one move not in two not in three
ever so that's why the engine says
totally
busted
this is going to be duda's first win i
can't imagine a player of the strength
and caliber of john shisht of duda not
winning this game i have to ask where do
you think it started to go wrong for
fabi was it just a situation that do or
die and he just had to
create opportunities or because the
opening seemed fine to me and i think i
think it was evaluation i think it stems
from this move knight a5 queen a2 and
the way that you have to follow this up
according to the engines is so precise
that it's difficult to find because it
goes a little
crazy right right goes g5 and you
imagine this will pan out
the thing is the engines hate it
remember that all the way back here i
told you guys g5 looks good to me
but the engines hate it
they're very cold-blooded about it and
if you put a knight here and you go d4
and you stifle the bishop
then i'm going to push you back
well
knight on h2 he went d4 pushed him back
and what are the consequences of all
these moves that bla white got in the
development black hasn't even changed
the structure on the king side or the
positioning of the rook and when
eventually the game blows up
white is better placed than black it all
stems to this
let's call it over excited g5 h5 that
wasn't followed up with absolute
accuracy uh they just particularly don't
like to move for g7 but even if you
played the best move the position was
already bad
i don't know guys maybe it was bad
understanding maybe
didn't really understand the plans as
well as he should have
because this precise move order that he
used with allowing this bishop to chop
off the knight on f4 all the way back
here i was telling you guys i would
prefer to be a little more flexible
about it yeah don't put the knight on f4
just yet because bishop takes f4 i feel
that's important in this kind of
positions
i mentioned that earlier in the
broadcast
and i think
once this knight did come off the board
yeah you got your queen to f4 but you
weren't able to create any further
threats
and i think that was the main problem
and we have this position let's move 25
in the candidates follow your mastery in
position with black is just that lost
and for
yes it's perfect for him
oh maybe it's time for caviar now yeah
very good upgrade wow
and here
here's why napo's fans nepo cartwheels
a point
and a half clear clear good god oh
second place
with four
rounds to spare to spare yeah you just
got to keep playing fortnite man one of
the things uh that uh all he would need
obviously is to draw out but one of the
things that people do forget he became
challenger everybody remembers that he
became challenger what a lot of people
forget
is he became challenger by losing the
last round
of the candidates previously in other
words he nepo had the candidates in hand
with a round to spare
he's doing it again uh alejandro and all
we can do is tip our hat and say very
well done he he looks
to be even more complete as a player
he's doing this undefeated
during the undefeated he's doing it in
style he's getting the positions that he
wants he's being very clever
about his preparation he is not afraid
of being surprised in an idol because he
knows that his territory he's able to
get a drearish but with chance's
position against rajabov and there's so
many places where his prep just shone
through
not necessarily that he had a novelty or
he got the positions that he wanted
right and he's taken it very well
another player that has a position that
he wants hikaru nakamura against alireza
forusa yasser you were mentioning i want
to capture this knight yeah
you guys even went as far as going for
the ideas of g4 yeah g4 does weaken
yourself a little bit
do it with a little bit more patience
otherwise it just played the move b5 by
the way look at how nice white's
position is
doubled rooks
good strength on the king on the queen's
queen side this pawns stuck right no
problems on the g-file because you
castled the engines want to play this
move
i love that move and that is a good move
yeah removes any possibility for this
knight to activate you never want to
give up this knight why because of these
two pawns right as long as these two
pawns exist and this one hasn't made it
to f5
the moment you give up the knight what
is going to be all over your business on
that square because this bishop can't
defend it right which means this knight
will eventually land on f5 and that's
game over right the knight dominates the
bishop from f5 so what do you what do
you do here
yeah just to be clear if black plays the
blunder knight e7 you play bishop takes
e7 rook takes e7 knight h4
and or yeah but and it's game over i
mean is this plus seven
plus seven seven you might as well
resign to avoid the embarrassment plus
seven and you're not even upon up not
even upon up bishop c5 is giving a huge
advantage to hikaru right plus two and a
half already
in a position where black has no counter
play no real counter play the only thing
you would ever want to consider is a
move like e4 but you can't play it right
now right i mean this knight is too weak
any any yes root takes a f5 pawn takes
maybe
maybe it's not a strong even though
that's a pawn
but
at this point the engine doesn't want
your sticking point exactly knight h2
h29
matter
to go to f1 g3 and f5 exactly it doesn't
help you this is not the pawn you want
to push you want to push that one right
and we haven't moved on the board c5
the engine's saying absolute destroyed
white's advantage i don't believe it i'm
sure white's still better in this
position just that perhaps bishop c5 was
a little bit more precise
well it creates a fast pawn it can't be
such a bad move there is a trick knight
d4 is that why the engine doesn't like
it no a5 is the move it wants just to
prevent the cementing of the phone i
think that's a logical move because if
you allow b4 i think it's visual
that well i was trying to win material i
mean unfortunately for black knight d4
doesn't quite work you have knight takes
and you would like to take on d5 that
was the intention but it's the same
thing this knight is worth more than a
rook
so queenie four goes and what happens
then queenie four uh loses material
tonight takes g7 if i felt like it
because you have knight takes pink takes
checks you pick that up
uh to be quite honest i i think that
even g4 should be winning 96 picks up in
exchange as well right so but knight g7
you have me at night jesus yeah and i
just was compelling enough he's played
alright so that is the move bishop fade
pretty quickly
which allows b4
that looks like a positional grip
of
joyous why would you allow b4 joyous uh
possession uh b
maybe he wants this knight d4 without
allowing knight takes g7 sorry no no but
even that just pawn to before that spawn
c5 is just such a nice pass bomb it's
never gonna that's that's just a
non-stoppable
monster it just never gets better right
did i tell you i'm liking you more and
more i love that the pawn on c5 is a
monster fawn
and it looks really
wow and you're not cemented right still
bishop c5 i i'm i'm shocked that he
didn't play bishop c5 i love bishop c5
it was just such a nice controlling move
but c5 looked
well especially now after the move
before i'm feeling i'm feeling uh very
uh
uh how do you say confident
that uh white's advantage is
it's decisive it's positional grip it
it's great i can't believe he allowed
before
i'm wow
how does this
like because we're we're watching the
best of the world yes for for me i mean
uh for me that's like automatic response
figure out what the opponent wants to do
block it and then you know smile on
their faces
thank you
so that's that's just automatic response
the way we saw him do this game as soon
as fabi wanted to go g4 no no no no no
knight touch two okay hold hold same in
the other game with value as a pawn c5
knockout daca's next move is going to be
an automatic pawn before uh
i'm trying to digest
why see this is how it was allowed right
this is how these guys trick you
they they play these moves and you go
wait a minute
i could play c5b4
why aren't i playing for the world
championship these moves are really good
i see these moves that's just my style
i'm very very specific with like i will
most likely miss uh
the complicated tactic or i will just
choose not to go down that throat and
she knows it he doesn't like it that
much
but i will very precisely figure out
what you want stop it and then stare
into your eyes oh boy it sounds
frightening uh
okay
so hikaru looking really really good but
now fabi has played the move bishop c5
trying to bring the bishop back into
play but it's too late right i mean rook
g1
plays itself and then suddenly
everything comes
you use the g5 square as leverage you
want to trade you want to trade a pair
of rooks essentially at the end of the
day you want to have a rook on the g
file so that you can do
this
which is absolutely deadly you're just
going to pick up this pawns on e5 and h5
and
fabi in huge trouble and i don't even
see
how do you resist this uh alejandra this
is
looking terrible what resist what is
this what he's just dead man
here you go rook you want you take that
rook you put the other country on and
right it wins itself there are so many
positions that we talk about that in
chess it wins itself the hand makes the
moves for you you don't have to think
about it there are so many games of
chess that we've seen and the
calculation leads to this particular
move down the road being important
because it forks and blob none of that
no no there is nothing to calculate
right the moves just win rook g1 wins
because it's the most logical move on
the board because it puts
pressure the black cannot deal with on
the g file this is the problem of favi's
position there are some positions where
we think it's hopeless but you know what
it's complicated right something will
happen right this one is not one of
those alejandro i have to ask you
because
um you were my coach for five years i
tried
something she's trying to overcome i
mean
now
let's say you don't let's say uh
one of your students was playing this
game as black
well how would you try to make them you
know what would you say after was how
would you try to bring them back to the
tournament after this this game because
there wasn't a blunder there wasn't
anything specifically that it was like
missed it just it just happened to them
against the
the person duda who is um at the bottom
of the tournament know when well um
maybe after today yeah so what would you
do what would you tell to your
other students i'm gonna say is a tough
one and it's a good question because i
feel uh one of the things i learned at
slu every person is very individual yeah
there are some people that just don't
want to be talked to after a loss there
are some people that are like you know
what let's let's let's uh go to them
let's do that let's go
out for a nice dinner and then forget
about the game uh there are some players
that don't get affected at all
uh rare
but it does it does happen they think
okay i lost the game it's part of chess
we go on this one in particular it feels
like a very tough blow
favi's been securely second in this
tournament since the start of the term
since the start of the event right
and for the first time we're talking
about people catching him
he's losing two blacks in a row
ouch this is really tough but there's
somebody talking about the candidates
guys right this is the candidates a
winner takes all tournament and 5 is
just floundering in the second half
losing to naka losing to duda things
that should not happen when you're
trying to get back in that podium
to challenge magnus carlsen this was a
big blow guys this one is a huge blow
for favi no question about it and we
talked about that
this is his road ahead
uh he had drawn against duda in round
three that's what that's all about but
boy that round 11
is starting to loom incredibly large
we're gonna have to jump into the
dingler in game and then he's got richie
yeah
around 12. but we talked about this
before you joined us with christian we
said what what's it gonna take for these
guys to win the tournament and we said
yeah yeah you you you can lose one game
yeah
it's not going to completely ruin your
chances you can't lose
two oh yes losing losing two is really
really really hard to overcome so losing
that one game in round nine fabby
that's really really bad but losing this
one
could be the tournament could be the uh
it could could be fabby's exit and we do
have rook g1 on the board oh pardon me i
think that's actually mine no i believe
you're correct g1 was played
oh sorry yeah
i mean dude took five minutes and you're
almost wondering what did you say what
was the alternative
exactly it looks so compelling it looks
beautiful and again you trade rooks you
go rook g1 rook g5 and as you say you
just
claim uh
it's just flat it's flat uh sorry the
dingler in game um we didn't get a
chance for mvl
to jump in and give us his assessment
he kind of just
mumbled something about three results
let me enjoy a little bit of my life no
this is great this is a great chest
because it's
fascinatingly complicated right material
was restored i was thinking that uh
dingle is up a pawn because he was upon
somehow he snatched c3 yeah why did the
rook come to c7 to snatch c3 it actually
took on c3 earlier in the game which i
think is fascinating right you would
think that's impossible right right
queen f1 and we have this position on
the board currently
both kings endanger somewhat if this
opens up this king is dead but it might
it won't open up for a while also the
bishop can retreat to h4 to cover uh
black's pieces look weird the knight on
e7 is covering the rook on c7 is
covering but where's everybody going
right uh you cannot take on d5 you guys
my first question
but it is too it is a little scary
because it allows this knight to join
the fray
it wins upon but the moment you see that
this knight might head to f6 you could
get a little scared not to mention that
you are also opening uh the e file for
my rook
your king is currently in the center i
could consider starting with the move
rookie one and target this pawn and then
you're barely holding on but that's what
the game is about both sides kind of
barely holding on while they try to make
their moves the enders want to play
simply knight g6 to step out of bishop
takes e7 also perhaps on a great day i'm
throwing a move knight f4 cutting the
coordination between the queen and the
bishop on f6 that might be a little bit
of a threat and what is black's plan
going to be black span is the following
you make sure that there's no tricks
against that against the king on the e8
and once you get rid of the tricks
you're going to take that pawn on b4 and
you're going to run
with these guys white doesn't have the
same possibilities this ball on e5 is
very well cemented and this bishop one
day will come to d4 if needed so the
strategical long-term prospects favor
black the problem is that this king is a
bit stuck not a pit stop super stuck in
the center for a really long time so
it's always going to be a target
fascinating struggle 18 minutes for
richie 31 for dingler and still 11 moves
to make in this crazy game um
let me take the pawn knight takes d5 e
takes d5 rook f7
now you wanted to play 94 first no i i i
don't want to take on d5 i want to play
rook f7 i want to force you so you don't
have that rookie one possibility
queen takes d5
and you're in a pin i'm gonna play
bishop
b7 and i don't know
where's the compensation well it's a way
of playing uh the compensation doesn't
necessarily have to come immediately i
think this is very important for this
game that there are many positions here
that because your pawns aren't marching
forward the spawns are marching forward
this pawn is stuck
you're not marching forward right now
okay so your extra pawn is a
theoretically long-term idea there are
many pawns in chess that you win them
immediately in that pawn because it's
central because it was useful
immediately proves its power i am an
extra pawn in the center i am pushing
away your pieces there not so much there
you're stuck with the power on a6 right
it's an advantage but it's a long-term
advantage
uh you could play rooks you want to
start harassing things the engines think
it's time to go queen c1 and start
tactics you have queen takes h6 of
course a little bit nothing to open the
h file but it does give you queen eight
shade attacking the king i am also
attacking the bishop here if you go
bishop b7 yes the engines say take it
did you take it queen h8 is a real
thread right grenade queen d8 right so
you have to be a little bit careful here
as black uh it isn't bad the interesting
this is playable for both sides if you
don't want to be as crazy to open the a
trial you can just bring the rook in and
then on
one day later try to exchange i think if
you exchange the dark square bishops
specifically there will be a lot of
weaknesses around the king the engines
don't like taking the pawn
fascinating position seriously uh three
result game uh chaos
and doris
how much time
has ding taken on his last move this is
uh
i would think we had mvl on the show
at this moment 20 25 minutes
to thank for the for ding 20 25 i
believe yes yes it was 54 minutes now
it's down to 28. wow i mean i'm trying
to remember what's things lar
ding lyran what has been his longest
think of the tournament so far
is this it
alejandro
i don't think i can have that statistic
so readily available i mean
dude you're my top agent for these types
of questions i'm really relying on you i
have plenty of recommendations guys but
it doesn't matter i want to bring in
this game this game is over
which game hikaru nakamura ferruja
the greed is real wait a second and i
feel that we've all lost like this where
white sacrifices and exchange right and
then goes knight f5 and then you realize
you can't move right the thing is you
usually lose like this
early in your 2300s
right not really at the candidates yeah
you just get it out of your system
you never allow it to begin to happen
ever again because you know yeah that
knight on f5 is worth man it's worth the
queen right why why am i giving a measly
rook up for it right and in this
particular version is just terrible uh
the andrew's best move is queen g4 check
you could also take on b5 moon
he
somehow got in after b4 this move knight
d4 and thinking it was good right it was
a tactic that we talked about earlier
right but after knight takes queen takes
it's just such a devastating position
you go check and only move his king h8
you go knight f5 and the immediate
attacks are already pretty strong you
don't have another move that's not queen
c4 everything else already loses
instantly to queen h4 okay just trying
to mate the guy so you have to go queen
c4 and you go this subtle but not
difficult to move to find queen f3 why
f6 f6 is hanging knight d6 will win the
game in many variations it's not a
difficult calculation if you go like
this
knight d6 takes check king g8 yeah it's
true bishop h8 you have bishop f8 so let
me just get rid of that guy first
and since i have a threat of d7 and i
have a threat of bishop h6 your toes
it's over it's dead lost toast host so
queen f3 challenges you to uh to find a
way
to defend against this knight d6 move
and it's not easy for example even if
you play a move like queen e6 i go
knight d6 anyway
you take i take with the rook thanks for
the tempo you can throw your knee for it
doesn't really matter but this position
is also lost
obviously yeah you obviously lost your
king is dead i'm taking on f7 i have a
passport and this bishop is great my
king you have no threats
i mean it's like very obviously lost
it's not that i have an engine you tell
me that black has lost you yeah of
course black stuff right queen takes d5
hikaru thinking he could go for a
greedier approach of knight takes p59 d6
the engines think that also gives him a
decisive advantage it's not as precise
but also good
uh it might be an easier calculation a
more human approach i don't know
i like queen g495 now don't play nine of
five immediately that's the only thing
actually the engines think that's good
too
because of queen e4 and you don't have
these tricks anymore
but queen h5 dangers are saying you know
what it doesn't win anything immediately
it has no threats
but we don't know how this is good yeah
we know how this story ends when there's
a knight on f5 that can't be
kicked out no light square bishop no
knights the rooks aren't going to
maneuver to attack this guy rooks are
incredibly clumsy pieces
so the only one that can attack is the
queen
and i have one defender that's all i
need well good luck with that but the
members of the pond grubbers association
appreciate everything you said including
knight takes d4 and knight f5
but
couldn't white have gotten the same
position with an e5 pawn being removed
by just
taking the rook
and going knight takes
in other words
hikaru wants to play the position with a
black pawn on e5 he made the right
choice uh
alejandro oh absolutely but i don't
think you get to the exact same position
right i don't understand what's the
point after pawn takes d4 knight takes
but here i have queenie for actually
covering yeah but i mean you're not
stopping me from taking control over the
f5 square right well yeah but your rook
on eight is active no no come on yeah
that's true i mean uh again temporary
slippery for opponents
yeah i was just thinking you know like
hey
all of those good things that alejandro
was telling me about my position uh
right now there is a black pawn on e5
this looks great for ikaro
duda
let's just jump back as he is
he is definitely cruising after the move
rook g1 not a good day for fobby fans no
bishop d6 a little bit surprising but
probably incredibly good move i mean
there's nothing wrong with this move i
think i would have been more tempted
just to get rid of this rook stop to
play rook chat
yeah it's over your move is good
overkill it's one of those moves yeah
you can take on g7
that's winning yeah yeah you can play
knight g5
that's winning this is why the position
is hopeless for favis because duda
doesn't have to choose the specific
right continuation to finish the attack
every way that he chooses that has some
kind of logic to it is good is good
right knight g5 was good
and to top it off fabi only has less
than 10 minutes for the next what 13
moves
when it rains it pours
that
knight g5 on the board and uh the
problem is
queen f2 dreaming that one day you'll uh
get h4 just allows the queen
to
land with
a decisive force queen takes e6 jack
so capturing the pawn on f2 he has
played by the way the move king h8
essentially saying if you want the pawn
you can take it i
i mean again white has just so many
moves rook g2 rook g1
even queen e2 starts to be attractive
never mind the fact that e6 i mean it's
just like the the roof is caving in here
on a fabby's position looks
terrible because it is terrible
wow
crazy part dorsa
how many decisive games do you want yeah
i think so too
four would be nice but there's already a
draw i don't think we can change that
and by the way in round nine the crazy
part the the only guy to draw was jan
nice right i mean he you know he
he bumps up a half a point at each time
in his rivals uh
it was team usa
actually falling uh to uh fabi
anikaru and
comparing uh nepal's result in this
candidates to his result
uh in 2020
2021
after 10 rounds it's a very nice
win in round 10. you could just like
around 10 i think he's he he's
he's doing great it's better than the
last time right a masterful performance
by
not only is he doing better than he was
last time
his opponents
are much closer together
yes when we were talking about the
previous candidates there were a couple
of people that just disappeared right
alexenko pretty early right thing they
ran early
you just never heard about them never
had any winning chances
when you think about this candidates
everybody's winning a game right
everybody's taking points from each
other last place dude is beating favi
right he car's being under alireza
dingleran just won a game
they're all taking points from each
other who are they not taking points
from
nepo nepo so it's not just the extra
half point he gave himself
these players fighting for second are
fighting for second
yeah
absolutely
and uh well from nepal's point of view
you guys can fight for the scraps look
i'm just here to take first place you
guys have a great time uh with the rest
of it
we did see by the way queen e2 uh
i admire um that he didn't day that the
marshmallow you know i'm not going to
take the queen takes e6 i'm gonna
i'm gonna you know like um
what did we what what did you call it
delayed gratification delayed
gratification thank you very much for
that rook g2 rook g rook g2 rook g1
would have been delayed gratification
but he just switched targets all
together he said look
now that you've put your king on h8 i'm
more inclined to play the move
uh queen e2 than ever queen g6 and i
just got a feeling that these rooks are
coming to the g
file and it's going to be
absolutely absolutely deadly maybe even
the other way which was d3 g3 just just
just to
mix it up on me yeah just a little bit
okay and uh
terrible terrible
hopeless right i mean it's painful to
see this because
as you were saying alejandro
back-to-back losses with black
there goes there goes the
event essentially
um again let me just jump to the hikaru
game for a moment we do have
knight f5
and what was that line where somehow the
rook ended up on f6 was that queen e6
uh i believe the line that alejandra was
mentioning instead of knight f5 earlier
it was queen g4 check first
okay
yes i remembered knight f5 queen e6 rook
26 i believe that was it or it was maybe
queen of three queen of three first
after and then knight f6 was coming
f3 was after queen c4 because right now
rush d6 feels like a clean win
right right right how did queen c4 get
in there again right now right now yes
and
then we were supposed to play queen f3 i
guess
looks very nice and we were
because of the threat of knight d6 we're
dropping the queen back and then this is
where
i mean
and the rest is clear uh that's uh
that that's absolutely absolutely
decisive
um dare i say it but
hikaru
preparation has been fantastic and
streaming is the best thing that anybody
could ever do
what am i saying i gotta
let me check it let me check out into a
hospital i i feel something what's wrong
with the world the world just got went
crazy how
do you prepare
for the most important game of your life
by taking an outside job during the
i mean go cut lawns is that the
he i think that's i mean there there is
a point to streaming and bullets and it
just gets you really sharper and i feel
like
um for me it makes sense that he's
finding this tactic super fast and he's
having that wonderful attack
because of his streaming because you
don't really do that much strategic
planning in a bullet game no
it's just like
push attacking by see you next game
hand-eye coordination right yeah like
get that
going and we do have um
the moves queen e4 queen h5 on the board
i see rook d7
uh
landing with a thump so i've got a
challenge i'm guessing
uh the open d file uh what's the story
after rookie actually just played
nicely nicely called these guys are good
no yeah we know that um rook the d8 um
finishing touches for uh
where are they nothing immediate but we
know this from previous broadcast when
you are down the exchange or you're
playing two minor pieces against the
rook your opponent has two rooks and you
only have one should you trick the
remaining pair or not no you never do
never so rook a1 just moved the rook out
of
contention right into a nice open file
give me the pawn give me the pawn and
it's a good pawn because i'll be able to
take on f6 afterwards okay so i've got
to defend it
and i think at this point we're looking
for wins right of course i mean i would
be kind of surprised bishop h6 doesn't
finish the game but well speaking of
bishop h6 couldn't we exchange the
rook's tango bishop h6 i probably can to
be honest that's nasty i'm not sure
i mean it's it's it's sad for black that
you can overwhelm the king the king is
so
the structure is so bad the knight on
that 5 is so powerful i think alireza
just got really bad after the opening
and it wasn't even an opening choice
because it was that weird night well not
weird but rare knight f3
nitro flying which i played as light
when i was like 12 years old but it's
been a long time since i've given it a
try
but at the same time it's it's it's a
very
nice chill move and it does question hey
your move what do you want to do and the
way that elias did play it it didn't
really
pay off for him because it looked very
interesting for for a while and the
players were spending hours and hours
and hours thinking about it well when we
had mvl on the show
he was saying that he didn't like ali
reza's choice of knight c6 he said it
didn't have the night or feel for him
and he thought that the
mainline bishop e7
bishop c4 bishop e6 where
you end up putting the knight on d7 it's
for for him the night or specialist that
he is mvl
he's he didn't like the choice of knight
c6
and the line that um
now he mvl felt it was more sfeshnikov
yeah like and uh white ended up getting
a pretty nice position that kind of
makes me wonder if alejandra can help me
out with this uh to the best of your
knowledge does ali reza feel comfortable
playing seshnikov because i i can't
recall
any specific game of him
in switzerland
no no he's not a special player so i
mean he maybe in blitz but no not in
classical chess that as far as i'm
concerned yeah so i i i'm having a hard
time um
understanding his choice yes and i mean
why play this type of middle game when
it's not your middle game that you play
so very well and by the way i i don't
know if rook a juan has been played but
i'm just going to refresh my board
it feels like it's upcoming but maybe
yes exactly it sure does it feels like
rook a1 just
and and you're right it might be that
he's thinking about rook takes d8 and
bishop h6 because he's got a forced win
in that line
i would be playing rook a1 just because
uh the principle of what alejandra
described
don't
don't allow the trade of the first point
it's a grand master instinct right
there's very some very basic rules of
chess that you learned through the years
they're very positionally obvious once
you come to them not trading the last
rook that you have is one of them and
unless you find a forced win
don't do it don't do it you just go lazy
grandmaster sometimes is correct
grandmaster
don't trade the rooks put it on the open
file attacked upon
youtube viewers i've been telling you
guys lazy chess is good chess i've been
teaching that for three years on youtube
people there we go we got confirmation
oh dear alejandro
criticized
i mean are you talking about the
ultimate couch potato over here you
can't you can't be dogging uh lazy
grandmasters
um
a lot of openings that i played whether
it be in english or those types of
openings was to avoid the depths of
theory oh of course where i'd actually
end up having to work really really hard
so i would specialize in certain
openings
like the nimzo indian classical queen c2
because
i found
those positions
very compatible with my style
this feshnikov position that ali reza
got
sure has not panned out for him at all
this move rook a1 looks really really
tremendous pardon me we're going to just
jump to the richard horror game because
whoa
alejandro it blowed up
i mean yes it blowed up
i was just going to tell alejandro
imagine you have a genie bottle and you
can wish for the king to be anywhere you
want where would you want it to be
i didn't get to ask that this was not my
choice but man i think richie looked at
this game and he was like that's a
pretty richie game let me make it more
richie
what he just like sacked the piece for
no reason there are plenty of good moves
in this position what plenty bishop a2
bishop f7 are the top engine moves i
don't know what those do but i think i
would unless i'm my blundering something
i can go move rook c1 right i can trade
this guy so the engine says i'm
blundering something oh my bishop sorry
yeah
so i guess he didn't find an easy move
he just couldn't play he took it four
well of course he think it wasn't going
to do
take it on c4s see we think with the
d-pawn it just didn't well we've got
bishop a4 check is there any reason we
want to throw that in i don't know i
mean
he has recaptured sorry he doesn't
capture it i think that if you throw in
a check
adding the move knight c6 probably helps
me okay i have to figure out why but v64
is on the board this is the current
position digler and up a piece you see
that you have an extra horsey over there
but this is the richer type of position
in which there's only play against the
king
this game is safe
now i'm going to give i have to c5
humongous thread right c5 queen goes
somewhere bishop takes e5 exploits the
pin on
this file question is what do you play
here to defend so queen takes b4 bishop
takes e5 is an issue yeah bishop takes
c5 wins this bishop and with that the
house collapses gotcha so you can't take
on uh
b4 you can't really leave this pawn
alone maybe that's why the move knight
c6 was actually
helpful useful for black because once
the king moves you actually are
defending the pawn
so you've got moves like
queen e6 to stop c5 queenie's is a kind
of a weird move right it almost
encourages c5 but the thing is bishop on
b3 is undefended even then i'm wondering
if c5 queen takes b3 and bishop takes e5
it's playable
uh check is playable as well the engine
wants to block with the rook what yep
just to exemplify the weirdness of the
position i personally am thinking if i
can get my running shoes in and just
king c6 and get out of dodge yeah dodge
nope c5 just wins
damn
we well you can't defend anything that's
kind of sad
bishop d5 check is on the egyptian
device on the agenda yeah it's a very
complex position so it's going to be
difficult for digloran to find moves
that being said 18 minutes for him and
richie's only is down to eight they
still have six important moves of chess
to make here razor
sharp stuff right between these two guys
what a fun game they're playing i wish
it was a little bit more relevant for
the standings
man what a game
i saw a graphic that my producers who i
never ever doubt
ever ever because they're always right
every day
every morning every afternoon every
night i've just been told that was the
most insightful comment you've made in
12 years
i don't know where this voice came from
they said well done aleandro they showed
me a graphic that said digler and
richard rapport had a combined less than
two percent chance of winning this event
well again it might not be about winning
the events but becoming in the second
true very place
it's very true on second position if
remember dingleran wins hikaru wins and
fabi loses
we have a three-way tie for second and i
am positive that there is nothing in the
regulations that says that there's a tie
break for a second it'll be really funny
if we finish the tournament with a tie
for second between three players right
and they're like yeah the match is
between nepo and uh second place
[Applause]
i mean it could be important it would be
very i it was a few years ago i think it
was 2017 or 2018 when i was had just
came to um us and i was living in saint
louis for slu uh i remember that that
there was a sink world cup that there
was a three-way tie for the first place
because there was no regulation
yes
abby magnusson
yeah yeah and they said
ross
they said let's not play for the trophy
and
somehow tony rich the sweet guy he is he
said regulation you're right never mind
about the regulations you guys worked
worked hard enough enjoy we've got rook
c6 on the board
and
well i mean the positions blowed up and
richie is the sixth best move by the
engine wow best move by the engine it
does make sense right it is part of the
idea of getting your running shoes
getting off of the d-file
aren't we encouraging no your bishop's
hanging
no bishop a4
stops queen takes f6
yeah you play four i think blake yes yes
yeah i mean
and king c7 instantly played and this is
the point that's your running shoes your
issues got it i'm happy to give that
exchange
okay help me out here where do you want
that king to be
it is running but i'm just trying to
figure out is it going to continue
running anywhere else or it's just going
to stay on the c7 well at the moment uh
it's begging
the question to white
uh if you um
i'm gonna take and then i'm staying i'm
staying on c7 and i'm a kind of a happy
camper quite actually
was it no i didn't know it was just
played you know i think the players are
listening to you finally i have to lower
my voice i feel like during these us
championships especially you know like
when they're
when they're in time trouble
that's when they really uh produce uh b5
alejandro take it over what are we
witnessing here was this genius
by
richard or was it bluff
we'll have to find out the engines don't
think it's that bad of course the
material balance still favors black when
you have two minor pieces against the
rook and a pawn you usually take the
minor pieces and this is no exception
the only difference is that this king of
c7 it's quite vulnerable right you can't
take on b5 i believe in this position
pawn takes v5 pawn takes b5 has not been
played yet but it is a possibility you
got to move the knight right let's put
it on a5 just because it continues being
relevant to the queen side on a5 and i
think that to answer the question yeah
the c file is open so the king is going
to step
one file further
go to the b7 square i think it's the
safest one the one that i would choose
because white has a dark square bishop
and not a light square bishop down the
road i think that b7 would be safer
and then i'm gonna put a bishop on e6
and it might not be easy for black to
make progress but at the same time i am
kind of cocooning my king
on the queen side away from this bishop
away from this queen and white is
running out of pieces right there's not
that many attackers anymore i don't feel
so fearful
for uh my position as black on the other
hand because of the reduced amount of
material where's white black's winning
tries well if i could you know just
close my eyes and pick up my queen and
just put it on h5 i would very much like
it but it doesn't do anything right
he's got the blocking bishop h i i got
this block for the rest of the game
right the only way you exchange my
bishop is with your own bishop
and if you do that then there's no it's
not checkmate look i'm thinking if i'm
black i want to cement my king okay all
right so i want king b8 okay i want
knight b7 and i want knight c5
knight before
that before a different approach to the
position it does encourage a couple of
tries it doesn't encourage c5 to be very
honest because queen takes c1 i assume
loses yeah i'm correct about that yeah
uh queen e6 has to be played according
to the engine and the game kind of goes
on
okay weird if you go back 35 played
yeah c5 you go back to ab5 for just a
moment because i really liked
ding's position after a b
knight
a5 yeah the end just gives zeros no
matter what zeros no matter what because
i'm thinking i've got a very clear plan
i want to go king b8 my king will be
nice and safe on the dark squares i'll
go knight b3 knight c5
and i'll start to target the e4 pawn if
i ever get to play knight takes e4 while
we're talking now we're talking why is
it zeros alejandro cause white has his
own attacks right the moment they put
the king on b8 i'm gonna have to try to
hunt it down this bishop is gonna land
on h4 no matter what okay so let's put a
few moves in let's put uh
let's start with unless it's blunt or
something let's start with bishop h4 you
want to go king b8 right yeah gambia
looks logical to me let's hide this king
a little bit further okay i just don't
want to have something on the first rank
knight to uh yeah b3 c b7 oh it's safer
on b7 all right same for on b7 sounds
good to me
knights love protected squares that's
right and i'm going to go
up
and knight c5 very good so now you're
actually threading stuff
yeah think before is the thread i have
to watch out for a few things the thing
is white always has resources because
your king is so weak i'm always going to
have tactical resources what kind of
resources check this out e7 rook c1 is a
move
if you take
i take on c8 queen five takes on e4
just equal damn it and if you play
something like bishop b7
after bishop b7 you're gonna start
regretting i'm crying yeah because
white's coordinated right right i'm
bringing my pieces to start harassing
your king on b8 which is forever weak no
pawns to protect it this piece activity
is such a and that's why we have this
position where digloren doesn't want to
open the position up immediately
queen e6 is played richie with four
minutes to make only a couple of moves
so he's okay in time situation and ding
has plenty 14 minutes and 53 seconds to
get to time control fascinating position
it does seem that the engines
find both sides play completely
acceptable
and that it was just equal all along
yeah it's chaotic um but you know half
of my eye is stuck in that knock off
your rooster game so can you jump to
that
absolutely absolutely we just haven't
done any second and this oh yeah this is
done done okay so we've seen h5 rook d
rook a1 the move we like rook c6 uh
defending both the a6 as well as the f6
pawns were
farouza's response bishop h6 this is
what we've been expecting that the
combination of the queen and knight will
just overwhelm the black king
sidesteps king h8 queen f7
for some reason whatever doesn't win
right away but rook a3
oh look at this queen takes b4 man after
your own heart yeah right
you're gonna die to the full tummy it's
literally made in nine after queen takes
b4 i mean he was busted but right he's
on b4 hey look you're gonna go down in a
blaze of glory you might as well do it
that is pretty funny okay maiden nine if
somebody by the way in the old days
this was very interesting in the 19th
century the players
uh would announce mate
oh chivalrously
i announced made in six but here it
comes
if it was a mate and seven you lose
that's so scary right because there's
like a weird stop move
right
now yeah
so you
you have to prove be be a person of your
word if you said and you just said it's
mate nine yeah maiden nine and that
includes all the queen checks and
queenie one queen g one right it
includes all of those it's really not
hard right you go bishop a fate you have
to take that bishop of course
yeah alireza has 46 seconds for if well
he's not going to survive but if you
were to survive
11 move
46 seconds for 11 minutes
okay and you got queen age six right
right you're threatening me i throw it
in the maid very good
you gotta go rook g8 and i go rook g3
hey you told me you weren't going to
trade rooks that's not fair
yes you
we've did a court stenographer in our
studio here you you be very careful
okay so how does he survive how does he
stop made in two
queenie one queen g one and then you
throw the other i mean
that's it that's it well that's too easy
yeah
nice one
even not we can do that he's playing
bishop f8 i mean it's just straight up
mate it's just straight up queen h6
threatening made on g7 rook will have to
go to g8 to cover the g7 square then you
just want to trade off that rook so that
you have mates on g7 and f8
and that's all she wrote queen takes c5
check
king and this is how
you manage to survive nine moves yeah
because queen g7 is completely
unavoidable and there we have it rook g3
i mean
i
i'm speechless what to say this is an
amazing bounce back
by ikaru i mean
don't make that guy angry
what happened the first time he lost in
this tournament
hold on he lost a fabby
then he then he had an e ground down t
more and then he ground down
after like six hours of just found his
nine maneuvers played great it was
unbelievable
what happened when he lost to timor
yeah he's beating the number two player
number two seed in in the tournament
don't make ikaro angry just just
don't make him angry don't do that what
a destruction uh to be fair
this was a very good game
i'm not officially no i'm not going to
say anything against hikaru's play was
very good i love this opening he played
very strong chess
he did what he had to do he caro has
officially won the game of course
wow
what did ali reza do today oh poor kid
allowing this knight to have f5 guys
i feel like he just got in a position
that he was just so uncomfortable didn't
know what to do with the king where to
put the pieces double pawns let me
defend him a little bit we get mated
like that in blitz we get made it like
that when we're 2300. we get made it
like that
back in the day but we were explaining
like how many hours ago that you just
don't let the horse get to this square
because once it gets there
you can't get rid of it we can't we did
it doesn't matter what the rest of the
game is right you get made it right
you get made it bingo um i was
explaining on one of our broadcasts that
one of the worst things that ever
happened to me is that eternal pin i had
a king on g8 and a bishop on f8
my opponent had a rook pinning my bishop
and a bishop on h6 so
my knight defended the bishop and i
couldn't move
this is one of those positions where the
knight comes on f5 and you just feel
helpless and uh this is not supposed to
happen
to uh
2800's this was uh a bad game by
farouja and we tip our hat guys and
congratulate um hikaru please alejandro
oh
this is another one
i like i love how alejandra is looking
can we get a clip of alejandra's
reactions just
if they're children and
please take the children out of the room
what is going on say something so we got
we we left it off here someone
five is dead you're right you can choose
whatever you want he chose this move
queenie too i thought it was a little
bit weird i mean if you sit down on
calculate 96 just wins right straight up
plus seven it's not that it's not that
hard even you take on e6 you take here i
take here if you take on f2 which is
probably what he feared yeah once you if
you ever land on this move yeah just
keep the queen tethered to ga because
that's where i'm going to mate you
this is nothing none of this is anything
right you don't have a threat yeah and
what do you do you have to move your
rook right rooko
you got to cover g8 as well because you
don't want to get mated on g8 that's
right
so
rookie 8 i don't know yeah or whatever
right and then knight g5 and you look at
the fact that you have knight f7 coming
od rook f1 coming and your pieces are
not playing yet i'm tossing in the white
towel it's over right well we need to
sure another way to do this can't really
criticize it that much queen g6 and
again choice of options rook d3 rook g3
was what he chose
looks pretty solid yep thanks rick dg3
yeah that sounds good queen eight and i
thought all right he's not taking on b5
requests about that stupid pawn take on
e6 hits both rooks you have to take bing
bing bing obviously you can't take
because queen takes h5 is made you might
think all right maybe rook g8 he trades
the rooks
okay maybe maybe queen of three wins but
you have to find the move and calculate
it okay look
let's go with that all right uh but he
took back on b5 all right no problem
pick up the pawn rook f6 and now white
is still winning he's made his life hard
because he's allowed black
to kind of cover
okay but obviously it's winning right
what i never would have thought of is
this following maneuver queen f1
what b6 queen g2
what queen f8 queen h3
what what
that's a very same strange sequence to
me
it's a good day for sans source and
louisiana's floppy fanboy fabies
i mean
what
what knight h7 look at that
cool move
you know
what
i mean obviously you cannot take it
right because something hangs right and
if you take on g3 oh yeah knight f6 and
you can't take on h3 because it's
actually made right
okay so the tactics are not hard but
it's a funny move
despite all this
duda still has a big advantage but is it
like plus five plus four no it's plus
two so the advantage has decreased
rf g6 is currently on the board
i mean i feel like white's gotta take
that there's well there's knight f6
right right none of this doesn't work
what because i take
and this doesn't work
you can't take on g8 i take your queen
darn so you would have to take back on
g3 right but if you take him back on g3
i just move my queen somewhere queen f7
rook g3 fine but actually but i would
play queen f7 actually rook j3 is
completely fine
wow if you go to rfg6 the angels are
saying only way to keep an advantage
rook takes rook takes and now
bring back this knight
what did you accomplish very little very
little and the knight on a5 somehow
snuck back into play well you've when
you go one
two
three you go knight h7 knight back
yeah at some point that night is going
to return wasted a lot of moves you
waste a lot of moves the position still
is very bad for fabiano caron it's still
very very bad the problems with the
pawns are still very strong the knight
coming to f1 and g3 to attack this guy
is also very strong queen f3 attacking
this it's still really bad if i had to
tell you that this is salvageable it's
not quite there yet right it's still
winning for white
however
but it's example it's a
of the bad form of dude of dude i can't
believe he didn't finish fabioff like 30
minutes ago exactly exactly uh knight
a visual that well
empty-handed uh doors yeah doris are we
going to get ready for a break and we
are again
in
what has become a familiar story of
three wins one draw yeah back and forth
we've got
two games still to go but we have hikaru
standing pretty as he has just won his
game and these are the current standings
with two games completed
well nepo is still
quite ahead of the rest of the
one and a half points thanks to his
early draw with timor
and that's the big game hikaru pushes
farrugia back to -2 i want to say
and he enjoys a tie for second
at the moment this will remember hikaru
started with a loss
against fabi in round one so this has
been his best
moment of the candidates that he's
actually in its height for second still
uh two games to to play
and there we have it what a roller
coaster it's been for him these last
three rounds yeah it's that painful
ninth round loss no draws in there
what do you think is he gonna finally
make a draw tomorrow or the next day or
is it just gonna be winning look i
picked hikaru right i
i had expected him to win round nine he
would have had the hat-tricks of
victories you guys would be
praising me
we'll see you on the other side of the
break
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament we're in round 10 where two
games
have been completed yan has made a draw
in his game to get today against timor
rajabov confirming his lead as hikaru
nakamura takes down the second seed
alireza
in a
very emphatic and decisive way bouncing
back from his round
what a game
incredible
that
he accomplished it so nicely and the two
remaining games well unfortunately for
fabi fans here in st louis i should say
st louis fans
where we're suffering mightily as that
game dude us playing the game of the
tournament at least from his tournament
uh to take down fabby that game's still
going on but the crazy game is still
going on also between richard rapport
and dingler and that's a huge game for
our tournament standings
if ding could win
and it's a three result game
uh he too would join
fabio it's it's it's it's incredible to
say but
for a second
yeah that's going to be because ding was
in the cellar
magnus doesn't play now that's what i
call a tournament
right three-way tie for seconds now
you know what i would actually like to
see what i would love to see frida go
you know guys magnus didn't play nepal
now you're going to have to play all
three of these guys now everybody go
enjoy a quadrangle four-player
quadrangular to take over over the
vacated title um alejandro we're going
to turn it over to you because this game
between richard and
ding lehren
is uh
at a full at a full boil
it's a crazy game and
we have
richard thinking for a very long time in
this situation they made move 40 right
and since then richard has been tanking
i think he's in a 16 or 17 minute think
at the moment wow deciding on what to do
and
the momentum
it looks like it's blacks a little bit
you have to be careful that after a move
like king b6 or even a5 just closing
things down on this side of the board
that you still have some initiative
right left and that's why i would
consider the move b takes a6 the problem
is bishop takes a six starts harassing
uh my queen with tempe and you know how
much you like giving up this kind of
tempe right no i don't know d3 is also
going to be an option at some point
a lot to consider here for richard and
that's why he is completely stuck and
just say zeros of course nobody cares
about that evaluation it's so complex
it's deciding between logical moves rook
d1 is one b takes a6 is another you can
throw in this check on f7 immediately
but i'm looking at queen c4 king b6
bishop d8 and i'm loving
that opportunity you're not gonna fall
for it this just wins right right now
you move the king off of the bishop if
you take what the queen queen takes and
at the very least queen before surely
there's something even better right uh
the problem is that after queen c4 black
has this move knight d3 only moved but
sufficient you hit this guy
okay and in some cases you start hinting
that this is a check now you still have
king h2 right but queen d1 is sometimes
made you got to be careful
uh for the moment a move like rook c3
sorry yeah
uh attacks the knight immediately but i
have pawn takes b5 where do you put the
queen you could take on d3
and this seems at first glance to be
advantage white adventist white problem
is that your bishop is stuck your king
is stuck and your king is super stuck
you don't get it back
this king
it doesn't do that it can't cross the g
file and this bishop is very far away
from challenging this one by the time
you get this bishop back i pushed my
pawn to b2
that's not good that's not good so it's
advantage black and they think this is
why he's stuck at the moment
because knight d3 rook c3 pawn takes p5
if you don't take on d3 you take here
instead i've distracted
your queen for a second and i can
consider going check
take this pawn
that protects and attacks protects this
attacks this there's some checks to
consider they don't really lead anywhere
and you're starting to lose the grasp of
the position this is something that we
wanted to do it was very hard for us to
coordinate this well exactly and
suddenly you are accomplishing it as
black so richard here has to have a
quite a long thing there is a kind of
funny draw according to the engine here
the move bishop e7
distract this queen from the knight now
knight f2 check doesn't change much
because it loses
control over the bishop right right and
after queen takes um on e7 queen takes
on d3 we have we still have this kind of
crazy position where the king is very
vulnerable i did exchange my bishop for
the knight it doesn't look logical but
because there is no knight hopping
around this king does feel more unsafe
you're a little concerned that this
queen is going to land with checkmate on
h5 sure but it's going to take a long
time for that king to find shelter
especially a position in which it finds
shelter and protects the bishop right
but in those positions alejandro where i
have two bishops for a rook yes i always
was taught that the two bishops are so
much superior than the two knights or a
bishop at night combination i would have
thought from a material perspective this
would almost be game over it would be if
the king was anywhere safe right if the
king was tucked in somewhere i'm sure
that this is just a huge decisive
advantage for black right
bishops should overwhelm the rook
exactly the thing is they don't protect
very well not against uh not against
attacks on the file eventually one of
your pawns will one of your opponents
when your bishops will
be pinned to the king okay and then you
just can't make too much progress easy
for us to say of course everybody takes
black in this position sure another game
yep
this one is
rushing towards a result
a piece up for white a piece up for
white let's see how we got there because
we left it off after knight g5 he did
take rg6 returned the night after this
venture on age seven and rook f6 was
played five was down to one minute at
this point dude with fifa and i felt the
momentum of duda was disappearing right
that he had made a couple of bad moves
and that things were finally looking
hopeful for fabi right
not to be
cool headed and collected this f4 move
crushed fabiano's dreams
it's an awesome move if you take on e6
and therefore i take on e6 and that's a
discovery against the queen a discovery
against the rook that costs an exchange
right if you take on f4 this is the
pretty point queen of three apparently
wins but i was looking at e5
takes and knight here actually the
engine thinks queen f3 is even stronger
but knight f3 does win a piece good
enough to win
b7 is hanging too oh that's right b7 is
hanging too you're right the engines are
not even looking that way they're all
about it
so kind of begrudgingly
if i brought this knight in
if you play queen f3 at this point i
still have queen eight to defend okay
um
but what happened in the game after pawn
takes bishop takes knight gf3 oh that's
nasty that's a nasty double attack
you're hitting the queen on g8 you're
hitting the bishop on e5
it's not hard now it's a material
advantage knight takes e4 on the board
five is still trying for those tricks
knight f2 is of course a threat queen a1
needs to be considered there but there's
only one logical move here for white but
it's really good but it's really good
hf3 so that you give h2 to the king it's
a very easy move to play and once that
happens well you are up a piece and
that's
that's gonna be the end of the game
yeah that's an extra piece or so i mean
amazing
this game had a lot of adventures but it
sure does feel like uh
now
uh
whatever slips dude made with that queen
g1 the g2 to h3 or however he made that
maneuver he lost a lot of time he's
righted the ship he's back in the
driver's seat it's reminiscent of that
game of hikaru when hikara beat favi oh
that he got this winning position and he
kind of let it go allowing this h5 h4
h3hg2 for no reason yeah that was and
then he was like almost there yeah and
again he had to find this like bishop f2
knight on e1 to protect and he found it
yeah same thing with duda it was like he
was on the verge of losing his advantage
right and he was like no no no wait a
second
let me keep it let me find some good
moves and he's done it i think he's done
the hard part i think the rest is
really not very interesting do that in
for his first victory of the tournament
which blows the tournament wide open
for a second that's a lot of fun
but
the one thing i definitely wanted to
mention was the other game and which one
i i you know i was just looking and i
was thinking that's yes exactly
dinger game um it was i'm just looking
at that bishop once yeah it got me
thinking it's been 40 moves has that guy
moved
you know i don't think it has i think
the rook went from a8 to b8 b7 to c7
so so everything's moved around the
bishop the bishop
has been glued to the board and that's
40 moves ago
and i think it's also kind of
interesting like you know i always talk
about how it's important to have
a purposeful development don't just get
your pieces out and put them somewhere
because you're supposed to get them out
right so this is a very nice example of
what i can tell my mikey my students
about you know how bishop is already
kind of developed
on its original spot as long as it's
open and as long as it's you know right
doing something it doesn't need to get
out because i have you know like people
play e4 e5 knight f3 knight somewhere
bishop eaton like wait a second why did
you put your bishop on e2 what's up
what's that guy doing there right so
this is a very very great example for me
and then my youtube
my youtube people to
make sure you don't just move a piece
because you think you have to it has to
be purposeful if your bishop is serving
a purpose where it is just let that poor
guy be man yeah right so long as he's
playing a role and i remember i i know
that very well from my
uh rui lopez days so i'm on the white
side of arui lopez and i've got my
bishop on b3 and my bishop on c2 got
this bishop on c1
so i got these two bishops kind of
angling towards the king side and i play
a4 and the rook on a1 gets into the game
and i never move my bishop on c1 right
because everything is working
efficiently and the bishop on c1 is
playing role in this case the bishop on
c8
has always been a part of the game it
just never
developed itself just never
made that little dance yet and if we if
we do see it takes then suddenly it
makes a wonderful
uh introduction into the play because
the knight will come to d3 where it will
be protected and
he'll defend yes
i have to say i think this game
excuse me no no no please i think this
game for me is like the the most
exciting game of the round obviously we
have so many other decisive game you
know knockout winning
floppy potentially losing but this is
just such a such a beautiful game and um
it was a few moves ago when queen c4 was
actually just played in the game was it
yes yes this was the uh players are
listening to you well in this case they
were listening alejandro because he's
saying
like knight d3 also played
whoa whoa whoa so this is the current
position and we kind of like
skipped ahead that the knight on d3
defends the bishop on c5 but for the
moment
it includes that after rook c3
alejandro was giving this line and i
thought it was
a really very insightful line that after
a takes b5 you don't want to take on b5
and the bishop is suddenly nicely
supporting the knight the knight nicely
supports the bishop it's the anchor boom
connected to the leg bone and that kind
of thing
but after rook c3 a b queen takes d3
it's very easy to be seduced and say hey
this is great for me
um i'm going to exchange up
wow until you kind of look a little bit
deeper into the position
running out of smart euphemisms for that
point sorry no it's a good you could go
bishop to e6
you could put your pawn on the b4 square
in the meanwhile notice that your king
is really oops it's it's kind of stuck
in the corner and this bishop is going
to go excuse me uh to the the f6 square
but it's definitely
advantage black even though your full
exchange down four pawn in that position
so
this game oh rorax c3 was also quite we
might actually get that very very
interesting end game i'm looking forward
to it well the one thing that uh the
desirable in this case bishop to d4 does
have a problem
i'm going to
give up my rook like
asap right as soon as possible
so that i can get my king
now
am i
still losing this in other words if can
black get his
black and
if black engineers the win of his of our
bishop
right we we better make sure
um
our king is
yeah
how do we do this let's take a look so
king king i think we're in time
by the time
yeah by the time the black king arrives
we
are arriving as well so like if you go
here
i think we can just
skidaddle up the board how do you feel
about bishop g7 to push that
quantitative dangle king g5 love it
thank you i love it love it i mean
uh bishop to g7 encourage h5
and then it makes it it makes it easier
for us to enter
um
okay uh alejandro jump right in on this
one uh
the ending better for black or just even
zero it's definitely better for black
okay but you don't have to be
as helpful in this position it does say
king b6 is winning and king b6 is
winning yeah partially you're going this
way oh yes you're going this way
okay and if we bring our king around
it's too slow way too slow i get to see
two right
yes
i can get into c2 once i get to c2 it's
over
because we when we get to put our pawn
on e6 we're
putting up on you six i have a bishop
how are you getting there no okay so we
go king f2 king b3 king e3 king c2 and
king yeah
right i should i should push my pawn
first just because bishop c5 exists okay
just good for you little detail right
but it's the same thing right right
could i go king d2 in that case
no i again you you don't defend
passively if it's with just the king
here right oh fair like for example if
you play um
king d2 in this position i think yeah
king a2 should be winning you're gonna
you should be running out of ideas
because i'll pick up g2 right right true
so i'll pick up g2 the way that you win
this is like this here here here you
take this guy well e6
yeah it doesn't matter you get upon
three seven okay and then i put the
spawn here i push this guy here i create
a pawn right and then one of the two
promotes exactly easy win
so you can't defend passively in this
position okay you have to go you kind of
have to go for it
so before you're looking at king f4
right right
but it's not even close
yeah there's no race to speak of there's
no race to speak of right b2 i already
took your bishop
yeah and you're gonna waste another
tempo because when you get to e7 i don't
take on e6 right right
now it's not that nice right i mean
that's why i thought it was a race
because i thought you were going to take
on e6 but it's not close you go king d4
and e7 you just defend against it you're
like way too slow here
so king
g6 yeah you're not on time you take
right i was thinking king h you're gonna
leave that alive
it's the correct oh that's the correct
pause that's the correct oh i have to
take it you're right you have to take
the pawn and then i'm gonna defend yeah
on time they're going to do three on
time now i did this without any
subtleties right right i could have
thrown in h5 as black i could have maybe
made it a little bit maybe a little bit
more accurate squeeze but the
straightforward inaccurate way works for
black okay so you don't really need to
think about it
it it it doesn't hold up for the black
for um
so no no early exchange sacrifices
uh
no uh but if you don't do that i'm not
actually sure what you do this is on the
board guys oh
didn't think about it
it went right for you he went right for
it he was like yeah of course i mean
worst case scenario to draw right best
case scenario probable scenario i'm
winning
so now rich is deciding between taking
the piece or taking on b5
very different games uh
but unless you're very sure that you can
get in bishop f6 and takes
you might not want to go into this at
all
um
you know i can't help but i i was boldly
stating the obvious this is like a
phoenix rising i mean because dingle
wren was so
out of this tournament i i mean we were
i mean i was just asking mbl what did
you think of david what was that
horrible results jeffrey zhang what was
going on he was like you know he's alone
probably doesn't have anybody so it's
expected but then boom he's back right
amazing what back-to-back victories
could do for a person's uh
outlook all right
wow uh
and richie exciting
oh what did richie do in round nine did
he lose
he was playing those girls
so we asked aleandra we go elliot so
what's going on here he goes i don't
know
and then we say you know what what what
did uh
richie do yesterday uh
before the free day queen played
on the board
yes i think i think whoa whoa whoa whoa
i think we're going right into it queen
takes queen takes rick takes
right yeah we're gonna define this very
soon fire hasn't resigned no not yet uh
bishop d4 is important
and i think it's very logical but it's
not the only move okay the issue is that
you want to prevent the sacrifices of
the bishop okay by doing it as soon as
possible like for example if i threw in
bishop e6 yeah and now you do this i
still have to defend the pawn right
right bishop d6 come on what is this you
let the king out uh-huh so you want to
do it this way but since you lost that
tempo
now these races are fine the king gets
to where it needs to be wow
that's why you should start with a move
bishop d4 instantly played
by dingle of course
boss move and now the the trick is
understanding that bishop f6 it's king
b6
maybe king c6 also works but i don't
know whoever plays that move when king
b6 gives you access to a5 which you
wouldn't have after king c6 now that
you're showing me king b6 can i play
bishop e7 and bishop b4
you could but
it just doesn't hold on long term don't
play bishop f6 just go bishop e7
right away yeah and it's the same thing
if you don't threaten
that guy that guy i can improve my
position slowly but surely bishop b7
look it wants to go king v6 anyway
that's a good way to start the end game
right
there but the thing is after bishop b7
at some point
how do you defend that
not easily it's not easy and again
you're playing down a piece yeah yeah
your rook is worth more than my bishop
but it's an end game where i have a king
and your king doesn't exist
it's just hidden in the corner tucked
away from everybody
so you're essentially playing down
material
point very well in the maid alejandra no
question about it that king on h1
doesn't
and
bishop takes e4 king c6 and you're just
gonna escort your pawns up the board yep
wow this is definitely a very beautiful
end game that's we're gonna
we're gonna go through that pawn on b5
is just such such a
i think i called it a baby monster a lot
was that another pawn there's something
maybe it might be
but this is a nice point that the bishop
after bishop f6 setting up
the
capture so that you can release your
king and bring your king into the game
is met by this very nice
idea of king b8 and king a5
getting to the c2 square to promote the
pawn wow uh
heady stuff and fabi
uh he is a piece down
we left it these parts knight takes e4
knight f3 uh clear easy move to find
queen c1 still kicking is fabi i'm glad
to see that knight finally made its way
from a5
but all the way to e4 and it's in the
game but okay now
uh we still have to win the game i mean
it looks beautiful and all of that good
stuff but uh what's the
what's
what's the
right way of winning this we're a piece
up here um come on dorsa give me an idea
i mean
yes the h5 pawn is still very delicious
so i would very much like to do stuff to
that pond i could believe you want to
see how okay um
well for the moment i've got a problem
right he black wants to go check does
something like drop
me back and
rook g5 i just said i want the pawn i'm
still trying to see if my wish can come
true well okay you
i understand i if i take
the rook
then hg and h5
now can i bother the king no
i would like that
no i'm the bye-bye queen
oh excuse me
i have to uh
adjustments adjustments yeah
you can run and get a check though but
the problem is what you said the very
delicious
they just had lunch this would be my
dessert
that's a good good dessert rook takes h5
is and this
is just i guess lights out because
the two knights are doing a great job
on g5
it's very good now you can't do it move
the rook yeah so rook g5 dorse's rook g5
looks
looks like a a clean win uh alejandro
you're like is there anything in there
yeah i wouldn't even consider it but
maybe that's why these guys are stronger
than i am
i would just look at the position be
like i'm up a piece and you have one
check so i'll play i'll play this night
here okay that's fair then i'll put the
other one there
yeah that's pretty darn good too lazy
grandmaster
what is this calculating nonsense you
put one eye there the other one on e5
and that way i'm actually covering all
the squares all the squares that i need
to and i assume once the queen gets
sacked if i'm mating you right that's
what i would do
yeah it's true that looks like a pretty
uh
yeah i mean you you look for the
for the simple and that looks pretty
simple
knight to e3 just stopping queena for
check
and you're set up after for example
queen takes c3
the other night nice drops in
and then white is ready to move across
and whenever white starts creating
threats
it's uh goodbye um now this is just a
very very
beautiful position like doodle has just
been better pretty much the whole game
so it's just really hard to imagine
well well that was why i was saying it's
so infuriating because duda
you know
through nine rounds of play hasn't won a
single game lost
against saint louis and he comes up
against st louis and he gives the effort
of his tournament
uh to uh knock fabby
out
uh i put it like that or rather you know
allow
two players potentially uh dingleran
already hikaru by the way has won he's
caught
fabi as we're speaking fabi's trying to
make a draw rescue a draw so that he
would be in seoul second but the reality
is the cold reality we think
that fabi's going to be caught by not
one but two players yeah ding is also
having such a wonderful position such a
wonderful game even though there has
been two well um two games are already
over
and this is pretty much over as well the
favi game most likely he is going to
lose
i still i still feel
so much more
i don't know i think this game the the
robert ding game is my favorite for the
day i keep going back and forth but this
is just such a wonderful um
yeah the whole thing is just
this is the crucial moment as alejandro
has been explaining
it's actually
maybe precision isn't
required but king b6
is the right way to go and after rook
takes
pawn takes bishop takes d4
it's actually this move king a5
and
it's a race
but the race
it's a race white's king wants to get
into the game but once this king
goes
here
here
b4 and king c2
uh black wins now question yes
how many more moves do you think the
players can go on without touching that
that's bishop on c8
uh you know there's a wonderful
wonderful sight uh tim crevey
a novelist from holland
uh he has the site where yeah
he has all of these examples of you know
crazy
you know the most sparkling chess moves
uh
the you know
the most spectacular chess moves like
bishop h3
by shiroff and
knight g2 by karpov against gary
kasparov
and you know chess curiosities right
and
what is the longest
move
player castles
right you castle you castle move ten
you're not a hero
what happens if you castle on move 30.
oh
or 40. so what is the longest time that
a player has has made castles
and on on tim crepe's site you're likely
to get that question answered
what game
where the bishop on c8 never moved it
hasn't moved uh up till now
uh how
you know like when did it take
black
move 50 to move a bishop alejandro in
your experience because i don't have
this kind of experience
oh i found the website
when did you develop
the last piece at the last moment
i know of this website because somebody
linked it to me because one of my games
was on it
nice
[Music]
one of the the best losses ever
i have the second
it is the second
most amount of moves
before a castle is executed by one of
the sides oh
that's nice i played 42
long castle
as white or black as white okay 42 long
castles so it was 40 move 42 and the
second
in tournament play
second longest before a castle so i'm on
the website somewhere hey hey you're the
top ten baby i think it's the longest in
a grand master versus grandmaster game
wow
okay
uh but do you remember
as we're seeing digler in leaving his
bishop on c8 through
almost the second time control that's
pretty extraordinary it is actually
fascinating leaving a piece there
for the longest without getting captured
or moved right
and it may happen that after king b6 and
there's this race where white tries to
move his pawn
the only time you ever move your bishop
is maybe to d7 that is kind of crazy
actually when you think about it well i
don't think it ever moved
back
but yeah i'm having a hard time finding
if this is this is this fact this is
chess curio you're a tim crabe
yeah but i i don't know i don't i
couldn't find the the bishop the fact if
there has been like a line right where
the but i'm looking yeah if anybody of
you anybody out there does find it
please let us know so
you're if you go to the site you poke
around it is going to take you weeks to
find all the cool stuff
uh
you know what's the best under
promotions
like under promoting to a night we can
all understand why you would under
promote to a knight that's really easy
because a king and a queen gets four
piece of cake or stillman or avoiding a
family how about under promoting to a
bishop
under what circumstances would you
underpromote to a bishop right to avoid
stalemates and stuff like that and and
tim has just done a fabulous job at
finding those answers right or if you
have fancy fancy chest syndrome fancy
chest syndrome like you know who's
afflicted
you make a bishop a checkmate or you
make a rook instead of a queen still
checkmate so we have fancy place in
fantasy play yes sorry and if you're a
couch potato like me
what's the explanation
but
the internet will know this the internet
will know this i'm going to throw the
question out on the internet social
media yeah there was a game
not that long ago
where one of the sites did that they
promoted into a bishop when they could
have promoted to anything just to be
funny right and they assumed that the
automatic recapture was coming
but then the the guy at the opponent
realized that
that bishop was superfluous because
the original side that promoted into a
bishop already had a bishop of that
color right and because you had two
bishops of the same color even though
you had an extra piece i didn't do
anything
uh bumping into each other uh it was a
fear game i think that fear was on the
defending side the grand master from
brazil uh-huh alexander fear that i've
known forever shout out to him exactly
but i remember a canadian championship
so a canadian championship the two
players were in time trouble bang bang
bang bang bang
and that guy is trying to promote to a
queen
but the opponent has cleverly taken the
queen and hidden it right so the guy's
in a panic
so what he does is he takes a rook
and flips it over
and says queen bam hicks the clock
they play but the arbiter says no it's a
rook
[Laughter]
you you put a rook on the board you
didn't put a queen on the board but
yeah right you know that's actually a
very sneaky
very unethical thing too that's what i
do like i mean like i was horrified
shocked shocked by this behavior no i
remember this was years ago i was
playing in this tournament and for some
reason i was always told that if your
opponent can promote and they like grab
the queen off the board even though they
haven't pushed upon yet
they it means they will they have to do
it so um
but it wasn't touch move like it
might she touched the queen outside of
the board preparing to promote but she
never touched the pawn on the board but
the pawn could be promoted and it was
her move
now
i'm in a lost position if she does
promote i have a tactic and she's about
to promote and she sees it and she stops
the america
right you know what i'm going to ask the
arbiter because i truly don't know i was
always told back in iran that if you
touch the piece outside of the board you
got to put it in
yes so i you know i stopped the clock
and i asked everyone like look i don't
know if this is a rule i know that this
is something i was told all my life
right now she has touches she's
literally holding the queen
and she can't promote
her move and she didn't promote so where
do we stand and the arbiter is like okay
give me five minutes he goes and he
looks into the rules and comes back and
is like from everything i understand as
long as she doesn't touch the the pawn
on the board she doesn't have to move
with i'm like okay that's worth the shot
and i lost the game but with minutes man
you're better arbiters
you're saying that the arbiter made the
right decision you made the right
decision should have made it immediately
okay i mean it is
pretty clear that touching a piece on
the board yes
it's the only reason it's the only kind
of touch move that matters but it was a
weird situation because like she she
could promote
she legally and it was it was i thought
it was worth a shot because i was always
told that and i lost few like non-rated
games but i was like playing for money
like that so i always thought that was
the rule so i asked and
so exactly what you described and i
remember it very very well it was an
interzonal in riga in 1979
in the soviet union and grand master
bent larson he's playing against
uh ruben rodriguez of the philippines
and reuben's played the game of his life
he's just unbelievable he's he's playing
uh terrifically well he's got a winning
position and he can promote a pawn to a
queen which is losing
all he has to do is make this one move
over here to prevent bent from promoting
his pawn and ben's lost
and then sitting there like the sphinx
on the board completely oblivious
to everything and you know waiting for
reuben to play so reuben reaches across
the board
takes the queen and he twists it around
like looking looking looking lurking
and bent
a completely impassive
so i asked ben well at dinner that night
has it been what exactly exactly in that
moment what were you thinking
and he said i was thinking about touch
move i wanted to go to the arbors
my opponent's been fondling the queen
please make him put it on the board but
he was afraid if he went to the arbiter
reuben would see
the trick
ruben didn't made the move that went on
to win the game yeah well opponent also
didn't make the move she
saw the last one she stopped it but i i
did i wasn't complaining i was like this
is something i'm confused about so can
you help us out so you know i don't have
to
feel weird about it later and the
arbiter was very nice and just you know
took a few minutes checked it i was like
no she doesn't have to move it yeah good
i had my own touch move guys that's
great but come on we have moves okay
king b6 i got to stop you this is the
position of the board in dingler they're
going right into the variations we
calculated king p6 was played and
accurately calculated by him rook takes
pawn oops
bishop takes king a5 king g1 we
mentioned that you might want to push
the pawn first at some point because of
some bishop c5 ideas he did it
immediately it also works king b4 was
good as well king f2 king a4 the engines
are saying plus nine that means that
it's plus nine it's a queen
somehow they see a queen coming on the
board and if that's what they see that's
what it is
it's about to cruise to a victory over
richard rapport with the black pieces
and type four second wow
well i guess alejandra did thank you he
did pick thing
sorry what's that again
hey wait wait wait wait a minute now
just a second who was the other guy in
the discussion
there was hicario sterling on his night
for a second
any reason that second was important
right wait there is there might be it
might be no forget about the money
magnus
is making the tournament interesting had
magnus not said anything before the
tournament started right this would
already be the most boring candidates
ever
because nepo is so far away so far away
one and a half points clear the field
clear of the field but if we actually
need to determine whose second place is
and we think that second has a shout to
be world champion
that's a big deal that's a very big deal
and actually it's somehow kind of even
ironically brutally funny
from the perspective that uh in this
winner-take-all tournament yes the fide
changed the rules and they said in case
there's a tie for first no longer are we
going to use a mathematical tie break we
want you to play on the board
we want you to play a playoff so can you
imagine that they didn't make that rule
for
the second player but they didn't
not there and we're gonna do
mathematical formula after all it
doesn't
there is no such thing you just tie for
second
right you only play off for first if you
play offer first then okay we have to
determine there is no regulation because
everything is extra official right
magnus hasn't actually sent a letter to
fita hey dudes i'm not playing right how
about you revise the candidates and then
somebody needs to sit down and be like
okay if they type for a second we play
off right none of that happened this was
just some interviews on twitter and
nothing has changed in the regulations
except the fact that we have play offer
first for second they're tied for second
great
i still think it'll be fun to have like
a three-way tie for the second magnus
doesn't play
wow
i can imagine a quadrangular a modern
quadrangular to determine the world
champion better than chess boxing
i don't know there's something to be
said about this now hold on our friend
george uh who's into chess boxing yeah
you'd like to have that discussion uh
what's happening in fabie's game
alejandro i mean i think we know what's
happening but just uh
give us the really really bad news the
lazy
grandmaster
knight e3
f4 he's gone rook a2 which is not the
lazy grandmaster that's
not lazy at all knight f e5 finished the
game i don't know why he didn't do it
but right i guess duda likes playing
chess like this if you take right
there's check okay king obviously to g7
if you go to h7 that's a discovery i
pick up your queen right right check it
queen takes queen on the next one gotcha
there so instead of king h7 you got king
g7 and i assume this is made let me
check it out here here whoa whoa whoa
whoa rook g6 oh you take on g6
oh no family four wait just no no it's a
normal fork yeah just a royal fork
that's it yeah sorry okay so you were
showing his mate king queen g2 king f7
and you were about to show us mate yeah
because this is actually mate right here
here and i think if i pick up the queen
it's good enough
i think this is even more precise queen
c6 but i think you stop calculation at
rook d8
picks up the queen so the knight is
taboo after the mover k2 okay can't take
on d3 which means that i can play knight
fe-5 or anything else later i can play
queen g2 i can play rocate what's up a
piece there's no surprise that the
tactics work in the favor of the site
that has more material
deep thoughts
you're up the piece and you win
tactically
wow nice
but
i have to say that the move rook a2
does
look a little
too fancy
it's a bit fancy i mean
right i think in any blitz game dude i
would have played knight fe 5 and just
called it a day as always calculations
go but okay rook a2 idea queen g2 idea
rook a8 sign score sheets very very well
done
uh and dingler in what you were saying
minus
nine well it's minus 60 now
minus 60. yeah
two coins come on how do you get too
high
minus six it's an evaluation that's in
placeholder when you understand how
engines work
it's kind of this placeholder of it
knows mate is forced but it can't see
that far okay that it just assumes that
at that point because of the material
because of the position mate will be
found but since it cannot see so far
away that it's actually checkmate it
just makes a placeholder
of a given number and plus 60 is one of
those that it finds a position that is
so completely winning it hasn't made it
into a table based just yet right but it
figures that it must somehow make it
there
and it's just calling the game
got it and it's calling the game with
this evaluation of plus
60. uh do i hear
i i know i've said this so many times
but i i really want the game between
ding and rapport to finish
as is so the bishop hasn't moved yet
at this point it's more of a
personal feeling for me i just want that
bishop rca to stay where it is yeah
that's funny it might actually go
straight into tim's uh website
well
i mean i'll send him an email and say
hey tim i i'm just giving you a heads up
it's gonna be a win it's been 50 moves
the business
grand master versus grand master game
candidates no less candidates no less in
which you win without moving any of your
pieces past a certain number of moves
right right okay i'm assuming there's a
lot of attacks where you win in 23 moves
and work on a1 never participated you're
just the only guy clear but
an end game right man that's a
that's unusual it's a curiosity and not
only that but if he ever did move the
bishop
the game was drawn
he needed the tempe to bring the king in
right right we you mentioned the bishop
e6
uh going into this ending and that would
have been a lost tempo and get given
white
the the the time to save the game uh
wow uh
again three wins i mean there was a
period there didn't we go through a
period help me out here we went through
eleven draws in a row it was no 11 out
of 12. 11 out of 12 which the first game
was decisive in that round and then we
had 11 in a row
draws
and and now the players are winning like
it's easy you remember when youtube was
asking well what's gonna happen to break
these draws and we just said wait for
the second half just wait for the second
half of the candidates things either
fall apart or start clicking and both
have been happening to players in the
last few rounds
so many decisive games so many weird
decisions
so much risk out there and some of it
just bad like blows back on the players
faces look at
fabi's
duda said well thank you for uh the
weaknesses i'm going to take advantage
of them yeah go ahead play g5 h5
exposure king
and
as soon as i get initiative on the king
side
an exemplary game question for you me
since you played in
alejandro is the national champion coach
get out of here
what yes oh if you could change
something about it
what
about the rules what about this format
i despise
the feed a
cycle i think it's all wrong
and i think magnus is right i think that
uh the feed a cycle as it exists has
gone back traditionally 160 years and
longer whatever
go back to 1886 and st louis in the
first
world championship match
but the idea is that in so many sports
you win the championship congratulations
but then you start the new season
at the same level as your rivals
and whoever wins the championship is the
new champion and so on and magnus is
sitting there saying
hey you guys are creating the cycle for
me
to find a challenger one of the
tournaments that you use is the 128
player knockout tournament this is a
wonderful tournament i think this is a
it's a million dollar term a one and a
half million dollar tournament i want to
play i want to play in that tournament
sets magnus you go
wait a minute magnus this is a
tournament that helps determine your
challenger you could affect the outcome
he says yeah but the organizers are
doing a great job i want to play
so he's saying you've got to make a more
modern
championship where i'm not just waiting
for a challenger i'm participating like
an mvl like a farouza
like a dingler and
each year we start at square one
everybody's fair and i'm not just
waiting for a challenger to emerge
that's his point of view
and that's fantastic you couldn't have
that in the past a player like gary
kasparov said look i worked really hard
to become world champion i'm not going
to give up my
rights you know i've inherited
these uh the
being seated in the finals and i want to
be seated in the finals here we have a
world champion who's saying
get rid of that let's play a modern
system
and i'm grateful
for magnus taking that approach but
defeated has been very very reluctant
to
accept magnus's proposal to talk
about a proper system
and when they do
i think whatever comes out of it is
going to be wonderful
thank you yeah very nice thank you for
sharing and i think also in the ladies
there's also a problem with the whole
ladies world championship the ladies are
saying
wait a minute
you know what's happening in the the
men's game in the open game is magnus is
doing it like this and you're doing it
in a different way for the ladies and
huifan
arguably the the the strongest female
since judith
polgar
is saying
i don't like the system and the ladies
either you know you've got to improve
that system
so uh
you know the feed has got its
work out for it it's not
the players aren't happy with the
feeding what i jumped in on this
conversation ollie hunter did i
represent the views of magnus properly
uh did i represent the views of huhi
fawn properly yeah you got all that
right good
okay
something so disgusting i have to show
it so we're on our conversation about
under promotion and yada yada yada right
and he sends me this this link it
doesn't send me anything else just sends
me a link okay to maurice ashley our
great friend
of course he's watching the show okay
even though he's over there in madrid
uh we got to this position apparently
this is some reykjavik championship i i
didn't get to actually analyze
where from where who
i got to pull out my phone again to do
it right but i just was mesmerized by
the position right apparently here white
missed a win okay
a really cool win queen f7
so if you go queen f7
obviously you have to take right pawn
takes right and if you play king f8 it's
pretty it's knight g6 mate that was it
was not made but it's winning okay but
that was my first instinct like why are
you sending me the stupid puzzle right i
mean king fa knight g6 is so obvious
right but then i was like okay is there
any
point on king h7 right because if you
promote to a queen
stalemate still made with queen h1 right
you can't move
but if you don't promote to a queen
promote to help me out here uh
i'll just use my arrows okay so instead
you promote to a bishop oh
nasty nasty you can't prevent bishop g6
and mate and since it's not a queen
covering the eighth rank right queen h1
doesn't work how cool is that
underpromotes her bishop there you go
that's what i'm saying a chance of a
lifetime it's the only correct move
whose game was the second oh it's i mean
i have an icelandic game between uh
nice wonderful welcome thank you maurice
thank you so much for sharing
why isn't he at the beach
what is he watching
what's he doing watching our games the
game actually did in a draw
what because yeah because white missed
it that that is so unfortunate oh jordan
son against anderson 2022.
what uh
oh man if i missed it it's gonna be so
sad and then it's on a show too
terrible right maybe i shouldn't have
mentioned
you bring out the worst in the chess
players
you're gifted man
we do have the game of ding loren i am
not joking
but we looked at this very line
ages ago yeah it must have felt like an
hour and a half ago right it really does
but it they've gone right down it and
it's that whole line where we were
looking at king f6
and b2
and takes and king takes and you think
push maybe yeah exactly you think you're
going to do it right
e6 and alejandro
he didn't take i made it a race he said
i'm just gonna wait till you get your
pawn
and [ __ ] you know it would be ironic
if this bishop moves and the bishop
moves and it induces resignation that
would be like no the one time the
the the moment the bishop moves then you
resign the game i would still prefer to
you know let that bishop sit where it is
it's been a good good little elephant
good little elephant right okay but that
that would be the the way to do it i
guess um
robots went king d6 which is
pretty much the same idea he's going to
continue pushing i'm assuming exactly
um
pause because
you could just pick this pawn up and
then go right back and well couldn't we
do that the previous time if the king
went to f6 true that too thank you
i'm picking up your pawn eating
ability yeah you like it uh yeah um okay
i guess if you go king d6 king d3 you
could also go back to e5 and he did
uh ding larinda just played king to d3
um i'm assuming you have to go back with
your king to e5 now but okay then he
could pick up the pawn like this
no
no
yeah it's just easier right easy it's
just much easier much easier yeah king
d6 is just easy king d16 d3 is just
easier to calculate kingdoms it's easier
to calculate the other one was winning
straight up winning so if you ask an
engine there's no difference right but
for a human why would i make it a one
move race right instead of just picking
up the pawn first exactly i liking d3
it's just i do too
the moment there was a pause i actually
saw it otherwise yeah but king d3 for
sure is is very
clear it's very crystal clean yeah um
let's jump back to the game of fobby
because what game
well because more or less when we left
it we thought it was really over but
thabbe found
a tricky move knight f2 i mean he's
still in the game without having to
resign but that's pretty much all you
can really say about his position
because he's forcing an end game down a
piece
there's two pawns hey let me let me
fanboy a little right right you can push
them a little no
yes you can
we're a bias commentator but we're not
that biased dude
i mean come on this is a piece um
it's a piece i'm afraid to say and the
worst part is
that if we try to push the pawns right
because that's what you want to do
the
this
weakness on b6 is a super easy target
and if we try to push the other pawn
uh similar story i think it's uh
the that the pawn on v6 is gets hunted
rook f5 hey wait a minute look at this
fanboy time again he's making it into a
game he's not resigning he keeps on
going he keeps his chances up something
favi does very well fighting moves in
which he does not have to resign that he
still has a shout you think about this
position when you resign
you know but i probably wouldn't resign
here with black no i know i'm pretty
deadliest let's see what happens right
you never know exactly exactly uh
i mean he is a little lost don't get me
wrong but i mean you you feel like if
you're getting
this far
you're there's one more palm left close
you know like ah closer at least right
closer yeah at least you get you got
some hope right
i mean it's a piece come on
and we are racing our way through our
three-way tie guys
this is just the piece and we can fan
boy as much as we want we can give him
with hope as much as we want but it's a
piece for john custom of duda in a
nothing end game right yeah the only
thing that's happening is that you're up
a piece and ding lauren is like pardon
me boys do you mind if i crash the party
nice
the chinese superstar is back wow after
a horrendous start against jane pognachi
losing with white not finding himself in
the first half at all right
and now second half kind of like the
2021 candidates
he's surging
it
it's crazy it's like the night of the
living dead or something right and he
was he was so dead he was just like we
weren't even
you know one percent one percent less
than one and i don't think that's
changed
it's percentage well if
second place starts to be uh of import
oh dear but that's what we're talking
about it's funny because we keep talking
about second place but it just feels
that everybody that's cipher second
place all of them combined have like
five percent chance now nepo must be a
90 watt percent chance at this point
yeah it's huge by the way just for
everybody about the position between
richie and why is white so busted you
think okay
bishops of opposite color uh i can stop
the pawn from promoting the problem is
when we do have a result i do i'm
watching it and i'm hearing it and i
want to say it i think he sure removed
his bishop it's true
black's king went from e8 to d3 passing
through c7 and b7
did all
the snake maneuver all the way here
right and the bishop never i have one
more thing to say
thank you dangler and thank you so much
for making my dream come true you did
not touch that bishop thank you thank
you so much
uh aggressive stuff the strength of the
eternal bishop alejandro discussed
it worked
and hey look at those predictions well i
mean come on
dorset joins the show and she says i'm
going to go with godzilla
look why is this still up there
i can't believe this we're all tied for
second
yes we're all tied for second like if we
knew something
like it might be nice
but yeah what a difference does one day
make everything goes up in the air down
up again
it's like a beautiful painting
all we need
is for nepo to stumble
and get a four-way tie for her
that's the thing right right the guy
stumbles
every single second place wins and yeah
we have a tournament
but there's still half a point away yeah
don't ruin this for us
just like i'm still coming to grips with
the fact that we've got an amazing
uh tie for second uh with all of our
panelists i i think that's an
dorsa i think this is really unusual for
us usually uh
you know
i pick magnus and he runs away with the
tournament and i celebrate my my
sagacity and in insight but this is
pretty impressive stuff that we have
going on
very very exciting with one game for me
sorry i just have a language question
please
so how languages do you speak or just
you know uh comfortable speaking chess
terms
right so i'm really really proud of
myself because i speak english
but properly not like the british and
not like the americans i combine
both
in my mother's british and there went
all of our audience
[Laughter]
my mother's language of course was
arabic i was born in syria in damascus
but i was my family moved to america
when i was really small
and so i was raised in the american
education system and my mother father
divorced i lived with my british mother
so i lost all my arabic i don't speak
arabic anymore
not even chess not even just a little
bit yeah yeah
no i mean just some dishes and stuff but
yeah very very very very few words it's
very very sad and
i've always
because i've written so many books i've
always tried to
articulate clearly and speak clearly uh
the english language it's a wonderful
wonderful language
but uh yeah i i regret my wife uh yvette
who's dutch yes she speaks
dutch german in english at birth nice
they're born polygons it's terrible so
whenever i go out to dinner and there's
a whole group of europeans everybody's
speaking everything except english
i'm like the odd man out of the table
i'll eat my soup alone you know i asked
about language because i just wanted to
talk about that beautiful bishop so that
bishop in farsi is fil which literally
means elephant elephant and to the best
of my understanding most of the other
languages that i've asked around i
believe in in indian hindu or uh
in spanish i believe there's still
elephant alejandro help me out here but
so i just wanted to kind of get another
perspective on if you were if you know
any other
well i think in russian that they use
the the the the bishop is an elephant as
well
uh
in spanish no in spanish we straight up
stalled away from farsi here yeah it's
alfield
wow i mean when you add the al it's kind
of yeah now it's ours now that it's
not in spanish but it has no secondary
meaning the only meaning of that word is
chess bishop well i'm glad that um i
really yeah so it's just unique to chad
unique to chassis wow
but yeah well that's good so for our
viewers if you uh
speak other languages and you want to
you know let us know what is
feel in your language
well
dr
genie singfield oh yes she wrote a
little pamphlet you know how to read and
write chess so many things and it was
exactly so like jeannie's genie smart
she sees all of these uh
grand grandmasters from overseas coming
and playing in her tournament the
karen's cup coming and playing the
sinkhole cup she goes hey could you do
me a favor here's my reading right could
you translate this to norwegian could
you translate this to could you
translate this to farsi and she's got
you know all the world's grand master is
essentially working for her
i mean well how did she do that how did
you did
and by the way we've got a victory
our third it's so easy suddenly winning
uh alejandro yeah unless you're sitting
in front of nepo
that's not that easy is it because nep
is cruising with all draws in front of
him he's looking at the for the future
and saying guys keep beating each other
right i love this yeah this this ground
down long games he's sitting so pretty
he played a four nights like two days
ago right easy draw against him he
played a catalan today where he had the
small chance of trying the moment he
went away draw draw he has not broke a
sweat in the second half of the
tournament precisely and everybody else
is killing each other
guys what an event
give me the standings come on guys
give me the standings i want to see this
we have three one player running away
with the tournament nepo with one and a
half point lead over his nearest rivals
of which there are now three wow and i'm
still kind of ding
laren i mean it's a miracle he is risen
from the dead i mean literally he was in
last place
i'm i feel like for me i'm always going
to remember him as the field that's it
the field
that's it what what a tournament guys i
mean we've had everything and this is
what we love about the canyon so we love
everything we have everything right but
it just feels that with somebody running
away with it the way that we have
the entertainment value somehow
no because these guys are giving us such
a show duda coming in with a punch
dinglerand winning a couple of games
thing is just nepo has been completely
untouchable right it's not in the sense
that we can think oh never is going to
lose a game who's going to beat him oh
and we have a well funny you should say
that because we
i think jan's got some real tough road
ahead of course he's in pole position i
mean come on one and a half points but i
do know that in around 12 we're going to
see an akaru
nakamura versus yan game and that could
be
young's white there okay let's not kid
ourselves true that white jan is white
in that game okay he sees a near rival
and he says uh draw
excuse me i'm white i have world
championship prep
are you need to equalize and then we're
going to make a draw like he did today
right i guess team will read java he's
not going to make a draw from wu5 he's
going to say i have a little bit of prep
you got to figure it out and then we'll
drop that would be great for him and who
does he play tomorrow well i've got it
this is too this is around 12 pairings
the one that we're seeing nepal was
white against hikaru wow
i mean that's a that's a big matchup
it's true but it would be bigger if
hikaru was white okay but what is coming
up tomorrow in round ten
and here it comes yeah nepal is playing
round 11.
who just got
destroyed
nakamura versus richie oh my gosh the
double white for hikaru the double white
for hikaru and the other early match up
there's there karan against ding that's
the big one for second place well wait a
minute
but but farouza could play the
tournament
game
of his tournament against nepo i mean
where everybody is he's 19 and vicious
and hungry
because if you're last in this
tournament there's so many players that
would just check out with the draw
tomorrow we'd really don't want alireza
to do that but
he's in last place guys yeah but you're
forgetting that everybody gets an extra
7 000 euros for every win do you think
they remember they remember
do you think they ever even remember
that this is a rule i feel like
they get the check from feeders like
wait where's this extra money
no i'm telling you guys uh tomorrow
around 11. i got it right here
hikaru richie that's the game ferugia
nepo farouja's bringing it i don't care
what you guys say
timor versus duda okay that can be
the quiet game uh you know the three
wins in one draw but the fabi
in game now
my goodness bobby ding is just huge guys
you don't want to miss tomorrow
everybody for round 11
come and join us but before we go
alejandro bring home the show uh final
thoughts what a great round we had
of course nepa was running away with it
but it's like everybody wants to still
be
within striking distance right digloran
wins with black he crushes alireza and
they're saying you know what one percent
is one percent
not zero there's a chance and if i'm
going to help my chances i'm winning
some games and they're bringing it it
might be a little too late we'll see but
they're bringing what needs to be done
oh exciting stuff oh wonderful
dorsa thank you so much i mean you're
just making the show that much more
enjoyable i didn't like the first day
which i thought went to until eight in
the evening that was tough but ever
since yeah thank you very much wonderful
see everybody tomorrow see you all
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited